Two one you're going to give me a two.
One of the ladies and gentlemen,
and this is how it begins.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you today.
We have a new sponsor today,
Brian,
who we just for today's show,
it's audible.com and if you,
uh,
if you're,
if you're interested,
if you like travel,
if you do anything where you're,
you're in your car and you're commuting.
Audio books are the shit.
I'm a fucking huge fan of audio books.
The Steve Martin one is the most highly recommended audible book you can
possibly get.
Steve Martin fucking doing it.
And it's like,
it's like listening to a movie because he's talking about his life.
I,
it's brilliant.
It's,
he's one of those dudes and I would love to talk to,
but I would never talk to him.
I'd be terrified.
Oh,
that's my dream.
I think Braille is kind of tough on audible,
but yeah,
than that.
They don't have Braille and audibly,
you silly goose look good.
They make Braille from the Internet.
It's probably just a triangle sound like Ding,
Ding,
Ding.
Like Morse code.
Wow.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that possible?
I guess it is,
right?
All right,
well if you look at like Sumerian texts,
all the old,
old,
the most ancient languages was a symbol,
a bunch of series of the same symbols,
like ones and twos and threes.
Like they didn't really vary that much.
They all pretty much look the same.
It's fucking crazy when you start thinking about that.
Like you,
you,
you could make Braille,
Braille works,
you know,
it's just little dots.
But that works too.
You know that you could literally express your language through that whole
thing.
Yeah.
The whole fucking thing that has nothing to do with audible.com though we got
sidetracked son and he a way,
audible.com is a great resource for any audio books.
And uh,
there's some that you can get from our friends that had been on the podcast for
like Bobcat Goldthwait.
He's got a great audio book called,
I don't mean to insult you,
but you look like bobcat cult weight and it's narrated by him.
So it's gotta be awesome.
And,
uh,
you can get that on audible.com and if you are interested in go to audible,
I can't even read anymore.
Ladies and gentleman.
Oh
Joe,
you need to start wearing glasses.
Oh,
podcasts.
Yeah,
no audible podcast.com.
Forward Slash Joe Rogan.
I do.
I need some reading glasses.
You know what you need to do?
You need to do it already does.
He goes and finds the coolest pair of sunglasses,
you know?
Well then he just by stops the frames and puts it in.
Well,
you know what it is?
This alien ware Laptop has looked at super high resolution and in my defense the
print is like tiny,
teensy weensy.
It's really hard.
Yeah,
totally.
Yes.
I fucked up.
I don't know how to fix it though.
And it's display more operators.
I'm a MAC person.
I don't know how to uh,
how to use this nonsense.
Isn't it?
Control panel,
display properties or something like that.
Where's that Mac?
I can't,
whatever.
I'll just deal with it.
Remember how the control panel and windows turned into like more of like a weird
list and it's like,
wait,
no,
I need icons.
And then you had to go back to classic view.
Now I can't find classic view and windows seven.
Can you,
I haven't even tried.
I know.
Um,
anyway,
go to audible.
Com
out of a podcast,
uh,
com,
but no audible podcast,
[inaudible] dot com
Ford Slash Joe Rogan and,
uh,
go check out some of the cool books at book that I recommend.
Uh,
one of my favorite books is the war of art,
uh,
winning the inner creative battle.
It's by Steven Pressfield and it's a narrated by a dude named George.
I don't want to say his name wrong.
Gui Doll,
L we'd all,
um,
but it's a,
that's one of my favorite most inspirational books as far as creativity goes.
And uh,
it'd be even better if someone could say it for you.
You don't even have to use your eyeballs.
Oh,
I just downloaded sex at dawn yesterday from Christopher Ryan off.
Yeah,
that guy was just on my friend Dunkin's podcast.
And I'm going to try to get them on mine too.
He sounds like a fascinating guy.
Yeah,
but your book,
uh,
this is Robb wolf we're talking to here is not available on audio yet.
Soon audible we'll get on it.
Son were also vods to buy a on it.com that's o and n
tea makers of Alpha brain new mood and shroom tech sport shroom tech sport is
and stuff that we were talking about that as the quarter steps mushrooms in it
totally legit is legit.
It's not cheap folks is not cheap to get.
It's expensive stuff but it really does work.
It's great for energy.
Like if you're a person who's like in a crossfit or you're in the Jujitsu or
something like really intense,
I really recommend shroom tech sport.
You will feel a difference and it's not like an edgy difference,
like a caffeine difference.
It's like a prolonged ability to work difference.
It's really interesting.
It was,
it wasn't a discovered by a cattle people or something like that.
They noticed that their,
their cows were eating them and being more active,
a quarter sepsis,
an old traditional Chinese medicine Gig,
like it's grown out of uh,
uh,
this fungus that grows on a caterpillar.
It's totally crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So there's all kinds of weird stuff going on with it,
but it's been in Chinese medicine for ages and then a limpic athletes using it.
It does some cool stuff.
That's it.
It's a fascinating way.
I mean,
how do you find that out?
How do you find out how many fuckers die eating weird things growing on
caterpillars and stuff and they're like,
dude,
okay,
this guy now is jacked and you know,
like can run up the hill,
the fuck a weird mushroom that grows on a caterpillar that's so ridiculous kind
of PowerPoint.
It's caterpillar,
like mock boob.
You became enlightened by spoken month.
That's right,
isn't it?
I mean,
what the fuck is wrong with people?
How does anyone ever find that out with all the time and the earth?
I think you're really hungry that day.
Like you're really hungry.
And they just noticed that when they eat this certain caterpillar that give,
that has this funky smell to it.
Maybe that's the quarter subs.
Mushrooms on the Caterpillar.
Yeah,
but how'd they figure out that it's the mushroom that does it.
Not the caterpillar.
I don't know.
Imagine if they fucked that up for a while and we were all just eating.
Caterpillar is hoping to get yoked.
No,
no,
no.
It's the other piece.
The way the wrong Pete and Shitty bugs.
Most bugs not taste that bad.
Contrary to popular belief,
when we ate bugs on fear factor,
I had quite a few bugs.
They really don't taste bad.
It's still the law,
the psychologic mouthfeel,
the crunchiness and the,
but they're really bland.
They don't,
they don't taste path.
There's a lot of stuff to taste a lot worse than bugs.
Anyway,
[inaudible] dot com go get yourself some shrimp tech sport son,
get your workout on.
We also have kettle bells and battle ropes in which I just,
I just started using battle ropes.
I have never done that before,
but man,
that's,
that's an awesome workout and awkward,
weird workout too.
You know the bus.
Yep.
Yeah.
Especially when it closed.
Yeah,
no man,
I'm fucking,
I do a caveman style.
I think it's important that everything you do,
you should be able to do naked.
Um,
but uh,
with battle ropes are,
it's like 40 foot ropes.
They're big,
thick,
like the kind you'd use like on a giant ship or some shit and you,
uh,
you throw your arms around,
he'd do all these crazy exercises with them.
Uh,
and it's amazing for endurance,
mad at something.
I mean,
he really blows you out so fast and it's really grappling specific to your,
you're pushing and pulling your,
stabilizing the midline line.
So yeah,
they're good.
It seems like it would completely translate.
And uh,
between that Kettlebells,
Chin ups and body weight squats,
that's pretty much all I do.
I,
everything I do is with kettle bells.
It's either kettle bells or battle ropes and battle ropes is a new thing,
but it's like I don't want to do anything else.
I have no time for just not enough time in the world.
I want to be able to get strength and conditioning done like quickly.
So for me doing the whole body like as one big motion like that,
you know,
like kettle bell type stuff or clean and jerks,
that to me is like,
feels like this stuff that's translates the most to real world's strength and it
shouldn't take you that long to,
and you see a lot of people spent,
particularly in the fighting team,
spending too much time in the gym and not enough time just refining skills.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They get to a point where they think that conditioning is the end all be all
until you fight a guy who's got great skill and conditioning and then you
realize,
well no,
I fucked myself cause I spent too many,
too many days running up hills and not enough days working on my head movement.
Right.
That has nothing to do with kettlebells and or a battle ropes,
which are for sale at audit does it?
Smart conditioning.
Yeah.
It is.
Um,
all this stuff,
when it comes to supplements,
nootropics are very controversial subject.
And because of that,
we want to make sure that nobody ever feels ripped off.
You Buy Alpha brain,
the first 30 pills,
he's a hundred percent money back guarantee.
If you don't like it,
you don't even have to send the pills back to say this shit doesn't work.
It does.
That's why we were willing to do that.
And that's why I use it.
I wouldn't use it.
I wouldn't tell you to use it if I didn't even believe in it.
I think there's a lot of essential nutrients that that can benefit people.
And uh,
most people aren't taking them official oils and you know,
and,
and eating a healthy diet and,
but there are certain nutrients that,
that have been proven and shown in task to have a positive effect on your mental
clarity,
your ability to solve problems,
your ability to see things.
And like the recent ingredient in Alpha brain f,
I don't even remember the name of this shit.
I should look it up,
especially with you here because you're super smart.
What's in it?
Ah,
it's,
it's all like,
it's nootropics.
It's all,
um,
vitamins for mental function.
If you can read all the ingredients in this dark room who pay like an eagle eye
mother fucker.
But yeah,
it's a bunch of a bunch of stuff that stimulates dopamine release.
Yeah.
It's all legit.
It's all stimulating your neurotransmitters.
And for me what it does is it helps,
I don't know,
it sounds ridiculous,
but it helps things feel smoother,
helps my thoughts flow better and smoother.
And we have a shitload of positive responses from people that have used it.
So if you're interested,
check it out.
Use a code name.
Rogan,
you could save 10% off.
All right.
You freaks.
Robb Wolf is here.
We're ready to get this party started.
We've got to learn.
Yeah,
cause we should experience.
Let's try it by day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
dude.
Hey
the fuck did you do Brian?
Hey man,
thanks for doing this.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate you coming on.
My pleasure,
man.
I'm,
I'm wanting to,
I w you,
you've sorta like this whole thing is Paleo solution.
Your book has like a,
I think started like I like a new level of people thinking about,
uh,
about health and about like what the body's naturally supposed to be breaking
down,
you know?
And uh,
yeah.
How did you do that?
How'd you like figure out what,
you know so many before,
hadn't you?
Will you know it,
I've got to give a bunch of credit to my professor Loren Cordain cause he's the
guy that did a ton of the research really early on.
So almost 15 years ago,
maybe further back than that,
I was a California state power lifting champion.
I was into kickboxing,
I was totally into athletics and all that and always trying to figure out what's
the best way to fuel my body,
like looking for better performance.
And I tried a high carb,
low fat Vegan Diet and I went from 185 pounds able to back squat almost 600
pounds down to 135 pounds.
And like sick,
I had all kinds of gut problems,
all sort of colitis,
irritable bowel,
like all kinds of poop related stuff.
And this idea of the Paleo Diet just,
it was kind of weird how it got on my radar,
but I was kinda thinking,
okay,
these,
uh,
these neolithic foods,
grains,
legumes and dairy seemed to have some problems for us with regards to health.
And so I started eating that way and then I was a research biochemist at the
time doing lipid metabolism research related to cancer and auto immune disease.
So I was able to experiment on myself and then also do some research and that's
how I,
you know,
this whole kind of evolutionary biology thing got on my radar and opened a gym,
started,
you know,
using
this with our clients.
Our Jim made a men's health top 30 gyms in America within a couple of years.
And then the book has been on the bestseller list for like two years.
And like,
there's been no marketing budget.
Nothing other than just like word of mouth.
People buy the book,
they get benefit and then they,
you know,
they just go from there.
That's pretty incredible,
man.
That's,
that's a,
a like a diet revolution.
And,
uh,
you know,
I've talked to a lot of fighters that,
uh,
take it.
Uh,
I know Frank Mir is not a paleo.
Yeah,
I'm sure a lot of other ones are as well.
There's a ton of people,
you know,
and,
and I just encourage people to tinker with something.
Like there's a lot of guys doing vegan diets right now and they see a
performance groups.
That's totally cool.
Like I,
I,
I think that people should get in,
maybe get some blood work before they start a change track biomarkers of health
and disease.
Do it for 30 days,
see how they look,
feel and perform.
Check it again.
Like it should be really empirical.
Like there's some theory behind all this stuff,
but you should really get in and it should be your personal experience that
dictates this.
And if it's not making you perform better,
if you don't sleep better,
if your body comp isn't better than,
do something else.
You know,
is a paleo diet good for everybody?
Or there's some different body types that would enjoy a different diet?
Or do you think that that's like the optimum digest for human beings?
I think it's good for everybody,
but within that,
you know,
some guys are gonna do pretty well on low carb.
Other people are going to bonk and they're going to do terribly.
So just for the,
for the total layman,
when it comes down to nutrition,
explain to people exactly what it means.
The Paleo Diet,
it means what people ate essentially during the Paleolithic people.
Yeah.
And this is a period of time when we really changed from the previous ancestors.
When you look into the anthropological record and when you look at our genetics,
it's pretty darn similar to what,
you know,
the,
the people were living during the Paleolithic time.
And we can kind of verify that with different,
like there's just a place to Max Planck Institute of evolutionary genetics in
Leipzig,
Germany,
you know,
and they do all the kind of scientific validation of this stuff,
but it,
you know,
it brass tax really it's talking about eating lots of fruits and vegetables,
roots and tubers,
lean meats and kind of steering away from grains,
legumes and dairy,
these newer foods that for a lot of people cause a lot of problems.
That's a fascinating thing when you think about it,
how our technology and our ability to process food and grow food and store food
has evolved much faster than the body's capable of,
of,
of doing on its own.
Right.
It seems like that it's,
it's kind of a fascinating thing with human beings is that we essentially have
the same bodies that cavemen did,
but we have all this new stuff that we've sort of added to the mix and haven't,
we haven't really figured out what the longterm effects of this are.
Yeah.
And you know,
everything from sleep,
like if you start doing some googling around,
unlike sleep and health,
sleep and diabetes,
you know,
we don't sleep the way that we used to use do.
The Sun went down and we went down.
You know,
the sun comes up,
we get up now we have this extended photo,
we have light on us all the time and it messes with our circadian rhythm.
The way that we released Melatonin,
the way that we heal.
So,
you know,
the whole lifestyle package,
exercise and nutrition lifestyle,
the way that we don't really interact with a social group,
the way that,
you know,
it was kind of wired in.
I think that that's why things like crossfit,
different gyms,
different social networks are really valuable for people because we live in a,
you know,
we're tribal in our DNA.
Like we seek that out and if you don't have it,
it fucks with you,
like at damages you.
Wow,
that's interesting.
So what,
what's fun about crossfit is that you become a part of a team and you're all
work together and you're like fellow crossfitters and you.
Yeah.
Well,
I see that for sure in Jujitsu.
I see that in martial arts it's always been the case in martial arts.
You know that your,
your gym becomes like your family.
Yeah,
yeah.
The,
the exercise becomes almost secondary.
It's like that,
you know,
making sure that you CPS.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's true.
That's definitely true.
It is fascinating.
How are our needs are essentially the same but wow.
Have we done a crazy job of changing our environment in such a short period of
time?
It's almost like we just really can't keep up with that.
What we've been able to do.
Our body just can't keep up with it and you know,
travel and shit like that.
And if you look at some native populations,
like they are crushed by type two diabetes and auto immune diseases and they
were eating basically a paleo type diet maybe only a couple of hundred years
ago.
So you know,
the,
depending on your genetic ancestry you might be able to deal with,
you know,
high fructose corn syrup or something a little bit better than somebody else.
It's maybe like native American or African American because their ancestry is
just,
just young enough with regards to being exposed to this modern environment that
they don't cope with it.
Like it's that much more damaging to them.
Wow.
So,
um,
what about processed foods?
What about like ingredients or processed foods?
What are the long term negative effects of,
you know,
you hear the processed foods are bad for people.
What are the longterm effects of eating something that has so much preservatives
in it that it couldn't just sit around,
you know,
it,
you just look around and you look at like the diabetes epidemic and,
and uh,
you know,
autism spectrum,
it accelerating.
It's just everything from cancer,
diabetes,
heart disease,
Parkinson's,
Alzheimer's,
all of this is related to this process called inflammation.
And inflammation is kind of an over activity of the immune response.
And interesting with the courthouse steps product,
it actually modulates the immune response.
It makes the immune system do what it's supposed to do,
whether you're under stress or exercising or whatever.
And that's kind of the benefit of that stuff.
And the negative part of the way that we're living.
We don't get enough sleep.
We eat the wrong types of foods,
we don't really exercise enough.
And all of that kind of sends a weird signal to our immune system and it tends
to make you diabetic or it can make you autoimmune or it can accelerate things
like Parkinson's and Alzheimer's.
So know we're,
we were facing,
there's some projections and this is from like,
you know,
governmental agencies.
There is Orthodox as it gets.
We're looking at by like 2030 that,
you know,
we're going to have a 300% of GDP being allocated to our debt.
And then most of that being allocated to health care and it's nuts.
You know,
we know more about disease and cancer and everything that we've ever known,
but yet people are getting sicker faster than they ever have.
It's crazy.
And it's just a lack of lack of nutrition and the lack of supplying the body
with what it's always had,
the essentials,
the vegetables,
the fresh vegetables and fresh meats.
And it's why does stuffed it's processed taste so fucking good.
You know,
that's Twinkies.
So delicious.
You know,
there's a bunch of food chemist that put all their kids through school by
figuring out there's this thing called palatability and if you can make
something hyper palatable,
like it tastes so good,
then you actually override the mechanisms in the brain that normally tell you
I'm full.
Like if you sit down and eat some chicken and some fruit and like some yams
you'll eat until you're full and you're done and you're not going to get up and
you know,
dust another plate of that.
But when you tinker with these foods and you make them really crunchy,
he adds salt,
yet some high fructose corn syrup,
these things become hyper palatable and it turns off the part of the brain that
tells you I'm full.
And it would be like,
you know,
you're filling up your gas at the gas station and if you turn off the mechanism
to know when the gas tank is full,
it's kind of the same analogy.
Like you just keep pumping stuff in there and you have a disaster.
Berlin,
how does someone get to be like 700 pounds?
And you see these people that have to get cut out of their houses.
Is that even possible without processed foods?
I don't think so.
And it's usually liquid exist before.
Right.
Just super rare.
You know,
hospitals are retooling everything.
Hospitals,
fire departments,
police departments are being forced to retool everything that they have,
their beds,
their,
their gurneys.
Even the,
you know,
the openings under doorways because people are getting so big and it never
happened in the past,
you know,
1950s it never really happened like that and we ate a little more fat.
We didn't have as much processed food.
We didn't have high fructose corn syrup.
People tend to sleep a little more.
Like the sleep is big.
Even on like the Food Guy,
I'm always talking about sleep cause it,
it just messes you up.
And when you don't get enough,
when you look at those turn of the century people,
they were all like little wired dudes.
Like they could just work all day.
You got wire read hood were called and they did.
Yeah.
It's weird how,
how much people have changed.
Like the average size for a man was like 125 pounds.
You know,
like we don't realize how fucking big we've got.
Right.
And not in a good relative and not quickly.
You're not good big at all.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's weird that it can happen so quickly.
There's a photograph from,
I believe it's like the turn of the century and there was a guy who was a side
show and those guy played the fat man in the side shot.
If the image came out like kind of recently,
cause it's ridiculous because the guy's not even that fat by today's standards.
Like there's no way you would pay to see him.
But back then it was like Whoa,
what freak.
Yeah,
I guess you would have to eat insane amounts of like regular good healthy food
to get that big and and you know it's that thing again where like you just,
you get full from real food so it's really hard to overeat it.
But if you have something that turns off literally the mechanism in your brain
that says,
I'm full,
like if that never kicks in,
then you can just keep going and going.
It's so creepy,
but yet so delicious in the air and lands the problem.
So delicious.
You allow yourself cheat days.
Will you eat shitty foods?
You know,
I do some Mexican food and I do like some corn tortillas and stuff like that.
I'm super allergic to wheat,
so it's just really,
that stuff's just a no go.
Like,
it can't have no weight at all.
None.
Oh,
your whole life.
Uh,
you know,
I was sick as a kid a lot and it was probably all like wheat and oats and stuff
like that.
Holy Shit.
So I'll kick my heels up,
but I tend to like to burn my carbs more from booze.
So versus I'm good moves for you actually.
You actually count your carbs,
just go,
hmm.
I don't really count it,
but if I'm going to,
if I'm going to shit the bed on something,
I'd rather it be alcohol then like pastas or something.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Twinkies.
It's just a horrible feeling when it's over.
It's like,
what did I do?
It's just so different.
So much disappointment.
You know,
like eat like a ring ding or something like that.
Right?
Like as soon as you're cleaning your fingers,
I'm like,
what the fuck dude,
real.
Then you want another one.
So yeah,
I usually don't usually have discussed it with myself after one.
And it's really hard to get a good night's sleep if you shit your bed.
Also,
I would imagine you need a lot of beds around.
Yeah,
you need some options with Twinkies.
Is that what you're saying?
Twinkies make you shit yourself?
No,
he said that if he's going to waste any of that stuff,
he's got to shit the bed and hit.
And then earlier you said that he needs a lot of sleep,
which I agree.
I,
I spend a lot of money on mattresses and because I need a deep sleep and so I,
I spent as much money as I can on just the bed.
Like I think that's Mo.
So,
but so many people spend like $30,000 on a car and they're in it for like 10
minutes to go to work back and forth,
but you're in your bed half of your life and like people buy like an $800
mattress,
like with springs going up your ass and stuff like that.
She'd have sleep numbers sponsoring shouldn't really cost more than 800 bucks
should.
Yeah,
exactly.
It shows Tempur-Pedic's.
It seems like they just sliced those bitches out of a box.
They the,
the tempurpedic is aren't that comfortable.
I just got,
I just got a new mattress because I couldn't take the cat pee smell in my bed
anymore.
Details.
Pat's was with the pissing and so I now I have this whole lockdown system with
cats in my house so they can't go into certain rooms anymore.
Now they're going to hate you even more.
Yeah.
I know one of them slapped me the other night,
but this came up to me for no reason.
It's like smack and then ran away.
I was like,
what the wow.
That's
how your political ways spot where he was pissing mad too.
So he was trying to piss in that bed son.
But these new beds have like tempurpedic and then the one I've got has like a
gel on top of it.
So it's like just weird gel that you're in and so it's like a little baby water
bed.
Wow.
You liked it?
Yeah,
it's pretty bad ass.
Do you uh,
recommend waterbeds is it good to be in that womb?
Like environment?
You know,
I like to sleep number actually.
Would you like that thing?
Yeah,
I liked that thing and I actually have mine like concrete,
like [inaudible] fired.
It's like 95,
I think is kind of individual,
but it is cool.
You can dial the thing up or down and make it fit for what you need.
I had one,
I didn't like it.
He didn't like it?
No,
no.
What do you roll with it?
Be better if a tent like affirm tempurpedic.
I just didn't like that one.
No.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've heard that you,
you can avoid like more kinks and neck things if you sleep in a harder mattress.
Right.
The harder the better.
Is that the case against,
you know,
it's kind of funny.
My,
my pal is a total sleep expert and he,
he would have grilled him on this stuff and he's like,
you know,
just kind of depends on how you're wired up.
I think that again is trying to get in and do some personal experimentation and
you should have a really good night's sleep.
You should wake up refreshed.
If you wake up and you're feeling like dog shit,
then it was a bad,
bad,
you need something else.
But our house,
we have like four spare bedrooms.
Each spare bedroom has like a $3,000 mattress in it from us trying these other
beds and it's like,
ah,
that didn't work.
That didn't work.
And it's always,
the trial period is like try it for 60 days but you don't start feeling like
shit until like 61 days.
So yeah.
And if your bed has that like sink hole black hole thing that's in the middle
because it's so old.
Got To get rid of that.
Yeah,
because I found mine on my last bed,
it had a mild version of that so it was always constantly like,
like having to adjust my body a little just to get like,
like a more comfortable sleep.
So I slept on my stomach.
I always had neck pains from on one side of my body from just adjusting.
And Alex p tends to Cathy Guide you.
Ew.
That's a fucked up thing when you go to sleep and you hurt yourself while you're
sleeping.
Yeah.
You know,
he just feels so stupid.
You wake up with a cake leg like come on.
Really?
I get Charlie horses all the time from dehydration.
From what about comics?
It wouldn't that be the way to go.
Hey Mike,
Mike be cool.
You could check out a hammock and they might be sweet.
I'm,
it seems like the way to go like a nice leather heel,
making your bed now sleep in a hammock man.
It seems like would support you like really kinda evenly.
You get pockets on the side of this one.
In high school.
Yeah.
I just asleep.
They held it up to the wall.
Yeah.
How much sleep does a human being need?
Eight to 10.
Eight to 10 pitch black room.
Yeah.
Period.
And that's like a no,
you can't debate that.
Right.
You know,
it's funny you people will say,
I only need like five or six hours of sleep.
And then inevitably if they put up some blackout curtains,
if they turn off all the lights and they actually like getting an environment
that's good for,
then they're like,
you know Ninja Blow Dart,
they're out for like 14 hours the first time you do it.
And then they start getting caught up on their sleep.
And these people that usually think they can get by on like five or six they
discovered,
they're like,
okay,
yeah,
I feel way better on eight to 10 and I mean it's a lot of time.
There was a lot of other shit you could be doing.
Right.
But you just don't do it as well when you don't sleep.
Yeah,
I agree.
I am a big fan of sleep and the fight don't,
I've,
I've really felt,
especially as I got older,
when I was younger,
I could pull it off more.
Right.
But now as I get older,
like if I don't have like a real legit solid eight hours sleep,
I just don't feel like all cylinders firing.
Yeah.
It's hard.
Even with a cup of coffee or whatever or an exercise,
you know,
it's still never really quite feels right.
It feels like he's just,
it's a weird thing that we just shut off,
you know?
Well,
and that's why travel sucks too,
because your circadian,
that inner clock gets thrown off when you go east particularly.
So like he'd go to the east coast
going East is worse than going west.
You know?
That's what they always said about Japanese fighters at the problem they had in
America.
Like Phil Baroni actually told me this,
he said the problem they have in America is that when they would come here,
like coming to America completely fucks her system.
Right.
How is that possible?
You're,
you're just,
you,
you're completely flipped around.
It's like you're fighting then when you would normally be asleep and it takes
weeks for all that to kind of get shifted around.
And once you,
you,
you know,
you do that travel.
So you go from Japan to here,
you go from here to Europe,
your testosterone levels drop,
your inflammation goes up,
your immune system goes down and it's gonna stay that way for a while because
it's a stress.
It's like,
it's the same way that working out or,
or working too much as a stress on your system,
it's going to drop all of your recovery capacity for one.
This is just because the interruption in sleep or,
yeah,
it's a,
it's that internal clock that Kinda gets tied into the sunlight and all that
stuff.
Yeah.
But it just drives everything.
All your hormones and road transmitters,
the way your gut functions,
everything is tied into these internal clocks.
So if a fighter wanted to acclimate,
but when he came to a somewhere,
who's going to fight?
Should he go there at the beginning of his training camp and never leave void?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And I wouldn't have it in your control.
I wouldn't travel more than three hours.
If you add control,
like if you have a well established fighter,
if they need to travel more than three hours and you know what a three time zone
changes,
then I would really recommend,
you know,
the camp at least a couple of weeks beforehand gets moved.
But possibly from the beginning so that you've got the continuity.
Yeah.
That's uh,
an element that,
you know,
the rest element is one that really doesn't get quite enough credit.
It doesn't get quite enough importance.
Everyone's always looking for something that you can eat,
that can give you energy,
something that you can eat that will clean you out and get you straight.
But really one of the most important things is just shutting the fuck down and
just sleep in.
Yeah.
If you sleep well,
it's hard to kill you if you're not sleeping well.
It's almost impossible to keep you alive.
Like it,
it,
it's huge.
And you sound like a nutcase recommending this,
but you know,
it's Kinda like my greasy used car salesman pitch is like,
dude,
sleep more,
you know,
whether it's clients trying to lean out or like somebody trying to get better
performance for fighting or like we had a girl that missed a Olympic trials for
the 2000 meter row by uh,
a hundredth of a second.
You know,
and you were when you were at that level where she didn't go to the Olympics by,
uh,
one,
100th of a second Polish.
You need all your,
you know,
your i's dotted and t's crossed.
And so like,
she sleeps well,
she eats Paleo,
she does all this stuff,
but she's still got edged out,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah.
But if you want to do when you're thinking,
but just to stop,
think about your life being about performing to one,
100th of a second,
right,
better then everything you do has to be like dead on you.
You'd be a paranoid freak.
You could be crazy.
She's been kind of crazy at times.
Yeah.
Like my monitoring that I honestly don't like.
Um,
monitoring super high level athletes because it is so fucking stressful.
If I shit the bed on something or there's the whole part of me doing something
wrong and then feeling guilty for it and then wanting to kill me.
And then there's the other side where you're investing hugely in this person and
if they don't comply with what I want them to do,
I want to kill him,
you know?
Because I know how important this stuff is.
And if they're like,
oh,
I'm going to go out and drink anyway.
Or you know,
on some other project,
that is a thing that drives,
there's a guy named Mike Dolce who works with a lot of fighters and he,
you know,
he,
you think guys don't listen to him.
He's like,
well,
I don't even know why they fucking brought me here.
Right.
You know,
it's just been pointless.
Like some people don't want to hear it,
right.
They still want to do what they want to do,
especially fighters.
Fighters have this mindset of,
if you like getting hit,
I mean there's a whole other wiring that goes,
you know what I mean?
They're not even that.
It's like they have a crazy sort of a confidence that nothing will ever go
wrong.
Right,
right.
Lots of some degree.
You need that,
you know,
and I think the people that are able to take that confidence,
but then also understand what a good coach can bring to the table and to some
degree,
step back and give up some of that responsibility.
It's like,
okay,
you're my coach.
I'm going to,
I'm going to listen to you.
Yeah.
I feel like fighters who herself coached only reaches a certain level.
I think,
you know,
you've had some problems.
If you're self coached,
it's really hard to objectively stand back and look at your game when it's not
going right.
You know,
a real true professional,
a guy who's worked guys through many levels of,
of uh,
advancement and growth.
He could see like issues.
He can find things that you're doing wrong.
And it just,
the,
I think for,
uh,
an athlete,
I think it's important to relent to a mentor as well.
I think you,
you have to have someone else who will,
you
also have faith in what they have to say as well,
so you're not in it by yourself.
It takes away some of the psychological burden,
especially for combat sports.
I think it's very important for,
for guys,
some guys don't like to do it though.
Why did they want to do everything themselves?
Yeah,
but you know the Jack of all trades,
you don't go anywhere.
Like if you're supposed to fight,
then you fight and you eat sleeping,
you know shit that and then somebody else monitors your food.
Somebody keeps an eye on your sleep.
You know you,
you've got somebody ideally taking care of the financial side of your life and
everything so that you can just focus on that one thing and you've got to put
all of those pieces in play.
Yeah.
Especially when you,
you're thinking about fighting where the consequences are so much greater than
the one 100th of a second and rowing.
Right,
right.
The one,
100% you lose that.
You're like,
Oh shit,
what could I have done differently?
I should have used fluoride less tooth place,
they start thinking crazy shit.
But when someone that one 100th of a second and someone connecting or you know,
spotting your,
your,
your punch,
getting out of the way just in time encountering you and you get knocked out,
then it becomes even more crazy,
more obsessive.
Have you worked with finders?
You Know Glenn Cordoza right?
Sure.
Glen.
So we worked with Glenn and then just more kind of Internet coaching,
you know,
trying to folks who've come to me when,
uh,
people weren't recovering,
they were starting to get a ton of soft tissue injuries.
Um,
bad sleep started popping up,
you know,
like they started getting some depression during training camp and everything.
And so looking at the Diet,
looking at lifestyle factors and I mean it all boils down to the same thing
though.
Like a clean diet.
I obviously I'm going to gear towards more towards like Paleo Gig,
protecting the sleep area like it at gunpoint.
Like the people sleep eight to 10 hours,
you know,
by if you have to kill somebody and then just kind of a mellow lifestyle outside
the rest of that to the best of your ability to,
to construct that.
But that will,
I mean it's 50% of your recovery probably is,
is having that sleep so you can go in and train really hard and then go home and
not sleep and you don't get really any of the benefit from the training session.
Even if you're working skill,
say you're,
you know,
you're working a bunch of head movement and stuff like that.
That is all a skill that needs to go from one part of your brain to another.
It goes from short term memory to long term memory and starts getting,
you know,
woven into like your brainstem.
It's a,
it's a learned pattern.
If you don't sleep,
you don't access that,
that transition.
So it's like that training session,
then it's just gone.
It's as if you didn't even do,
it's crazy.
So it's like,
if you're going to spend the time to do it,
there's a great book and it another good dude you should have on that wrote the,
uh,
the talent code and talking about like needing really good repetitions and like
10,000 repetitions and something like playing violin or learning,
you know,
uh,
quickdraw shooting and stuff like that.
You want to do it perfect and then you need a good environment for that stuff to
kind of cook in the brain and actually become a part of your person,
part of the motor memory.
So it's a huge part of the game that people are just kind of,
again,
shitting the bed on and,
and not get,
you know,
you see
so many people work so hard,
but they almost work too hard and then they don't give enough credence to the
rest because it's like,
God,
that's being lazy.
I knew his work ethic and he could go all damn game on.
Yeah.
Just to push to your break,
there's a lot of wrestlers I think that is the most overtrained and
undernourished sport when it comes to amateurs.
Tough.
They're used to being tough.
It's why they're so dangerous when they become an a may fighters is because
their,
their level of mental toughness is I believe above and above,
beyond any other sport.
I think at the highest levels of wrestling,
I think that the most mentally tough guys in the world,
they're fucking animals.
Those guys,
they don't eat for days and then they go and wrestle savages.
You know,
it just the weight cutting alone,
the fact that they have to be miserable and malnourished and dehydrated and
training,
it's really hard.
But,
but that's not the way to do it.
Right.
If you want like optimum performance and it's great that it makes him so tough.
But I mean,
if you really want to take care of the body,
that is so not the way to do it.
Yeah.
I mean,
staying within,
staying in close to contest shape,
year round,
kicking your heels up a little bit.
But you know,
the,
the thing is,
is that when people go so extreme then when their off season to gain 30 pounds
of weight and it's all hookers and cocaine is,
you know,
it's,
it's like bad bad scene there.
But what about the overtraining?
I mean there is a,
there's a certain,
there's a certain point of no return,
right?
Where you're,
you're actually doing damage to your conditioning.
Right.
And you know,
really common too.
It's super common.
Uh,
the people who manage it well,
those are the folks that succeed I think more.
And the people who manage it well or certainly the ones who protect their
conditioning year round,
they don't ever let themselves get out of condition.
And it's a very difficult and discipline thing to maintain,
like to maintain like a real high level of conditioning.
But if you don't have a high level,
you can't push to a higher level.
Right,
right.
And for a lot of people,
it's like when you have a,
you attain a certain level and then you drop off drastically and then it's all
about getting your,
your body back in shape.
Like guys who get really big in between fights,
like you know,
that those guys like that's not the same level of commitment as say an Anderson
Silva or George Saint Pierre.
The,
you're never going to see those guys fat whenever.
Never going to go see those guys in,
in between fights,
just drinking and fucking around.
There's none of that going on,
right?
They're protecting their vehicle.
And so even though there's still obviously moving a lot of scale weight to make
weigh ins,
it's not as dramatic a shift.
And just like when we travel,
whenever you change these internal,
uh,
kind of kind of signaling the biological signaling and you wait,
when you fly,
you know,
from a six time zones or eight times zones that messes with your sleep.
If you are taking your body and forcing it to shed a bunch of weight very,
very rapidly because you got out of shape,
then it's more of a stress and it drops testosterone and it impacts your immune
system.
So staying as close as you can,
you know,
obviously like you want to be as big and strong and muscular as you can at any
given body weight and if,
but
within striking distance,
being able to go down and make weight when you need to make it.
When you see guys,
uh,
I don't know how aware you are of a,
there's some crazy wait cutters out there.
The most recent one that I heard of is Travis view,
right?
Fought in Bellator at 245 pounds in the cage.
Two Oh five is what he weighed in at.
Right.
That's fucking crazy.
I mean,
that is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
And I mean there's some science to it.
You need somebody there with your,
you know,
your ivs and,
and all the rest of it.
But Holy Shit,
what a nutty idea.
The fact that you're almost dead 24 hours before you have a cage fight.
You know,
I would,
I think it'd be cool to just see almost like chits where you,
you show up and you step on the scale and you weigh what you weigh and then it,
it just goes,
yeah,
I would like to see that too.
But you can't do that if you have contracts,
you know,
because dude's,
if they don't have any consequences for not being at a certain weight,
dudes are just going to get huge.
Right.
I mean there's a benefit to just putting on muscle mass,
you know,
the 147 weight class,
you show up at 160 pounds.
Swole as fuck.
Like what the hell is going on.
But I mean they would sit then those guys would have to fight like one 55.
You couldn't,
you know,
couldn't do that in the world of championship finding.
Cause you know,
you obviously have to schedule it long in advance.
You have to put it on paper view.
Uh,
so the,
you got to have weight classes,
but there's no way to stop people from cutting weight if that's going to be the
case.
The,
the good thing that they've done is at least give them 24 hours to rehydrate.
Right.
Which they didn't used to do the old days of boxing.
He used to weigh in on the day of the fight and guys would dehydrate,
make weight and then,
you know,
drink milk and eat cheese and meat or something stupid and be all fucked up.
By the time I got into the and still dehydrated.
Yeah,
completely.
Does the Ivy Dehydrate,
uh,
when,
when they rehydrate with Ivs,
does it replenish the brain as well?
What replenishes everything?
But I mean,
the is in a pretty rough state by that point.
So I mean,
it's a 24 hours,
you can bounce back pretty good.
And particularly,
you know,
like you said with wrestlers,
they've been used to pulling their body up and down like that.
So they're a little bit more,
uh,
climatized to it,
but it's rough.
How,
how much of a percentage do you think it takes away from them?
I mean,
is it,
it's gotta be a damn.
I mean,
if you're not supposed to get drunk.
Okay.
And while you're in training camp and you eat clean and everything like that and
then you do something way worse than getting drunk,
you get crazy dehydrated.
You mean you've starved?
I've seen guys shuffling to the scale because they can't pick their feet up.
Right.
I've seen that.
And then we're going to find a world championship the next day.
Yeah.
I don't know when that,
that's where,
you know,
we're,
we're the,
are they its lien as they could be,
you know,
just day in and day out and uh,
I don't know because it takes something off and then you just have to wonder,
is it taking an equal amount out of both parties?
Because that's crazy.
I mean,
there's gotta be a way to find people that are really the same size and just
make some sort of an honorable agreement to never get over a certain weight and
just do it at the weight you actually are at.
Right.
Yeah.
And you know,
in some ways I think it would be more exciting fighting because a lot of the
fatigue that I see Seddon and folks,
it's probably the weight cut you saw like Chris Weidman and Damien Maia.
I don't know if you saw that,
but it was on Fox.
Both guys were,
well Damien Maia really just couldn't do anything with Weidman and Weidman was
way too tired from the weight cut cause he had took the fight on really short
notice.
So the guy had a cut like some insane amount of weight the day before.
And that's what they kept saying to him.
I saw what you did yesterday when you made weight,
you know,
you can do anything,
you can do anything like,
so it was like,
God,
the wakeup must've been definitely Mike.
Yeah.
And then here he is fighting on Fox,
you know,
the next day,
24 hours later.
So we're really a weird practice.
I wish we could avoid it,
but I don't know how,
because there's,
when you,
you have to have a way classes,
right?
You have to,
there's no way a guy like Joe Benevidez should be fighting Brock Lesnar,
right?
So we got our weight classes.
This isn't 1993.
Right?
So if you're going to have weight classes,
it's like what?
How do you set them up?
You know what if you would just set them up every ideally every 10 pounds,
every five pounds,
how do you set them up to keep people from cutting the Wayne?
I don't think you can write,
well,
I mean,
again,
you would do it more like a Jujitsu tournament where you weighed the weight,
but how could you do that with a championship fight?
Because if the guy didn't make the weight and everybody flew in from Australia
to see the fight,
you know what I mean?
It's like probably like curbside execution then.
I don't know.
Why would you get killed if you don't make weight?
And even then,
they would try to be as big as possible.
Right.
People,
I mean,
people,
there's an advantage to being big,
you know,
look at,
uh,
what it's done to Alistair Overeem.
Right?
You know,
there's Alistair Overeem one,
you know,
where it was a really good fighter,
very skilled,
and there's over him to where he's just fucking behemoth that smashing people.
And when the k one Grand Prix and the only difference between those is a lot of
fucking muscle,
a lot of experience and a lot of muscle,
you know,
it's,
it's amazing how much it does for a really technical guy when they get strong.
Right.
You know,
that's,
that shit's so how are you going to have a weight class?
I don't know.
I think to have a way in the same day due to get it up.
Sorry,
I'm 20 pounds overweight.
Not much I can do about it now.
I mean,
we wouldn't want me to dehydrate and risk dying.
And what the fuck do you get them to do?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Other than again,
the,
a curbside execution,
you know,
part of your contract,
you're like,
you're going to make weight or be some sort of Samurai type thing.
Told to be an honorable who out there.
No,
I'm not even that.
I'm saying like the,
the uh,
the contract to fight it should be like they should know.
No one should ever miss.
Wait.
It should always be like really,
really clean and easy and everyone's just,
this is what you weigh.
And then he'd go and fight.
That would be the ideal thing to do.
The danger is apparently,
um,
with dehydration,
that's when,
uh,
most of the boxing brain damage fights where guys have died.
Yeah.
Gerald Mcclellan who was a famous wait cutter.
He's a really big guy.
A lot of those guys in the heavyweight division and really never had the same
problems that guys in the lighter weight divisions too.
Right.
That's a,
it's a very unfortunate aspect of,
of fighting men.
Yeah.
I mean you're already taking something that's pretty scary and dangerous and
then making it way more.
Yeah.
What did the physical effects of dehydration on the brain,
because that's where it gets really weird,
right?
You could have electrolyte imbalances where things are just literally not firing
and your heart may not fire properly.
But I think a lot of it is just that that fluid around the brain is the shock
absorber,
right?
So if you pull some of that away,
then the brain is literally,
you've almost got like,
it's kind of like a walnut that fills the whole shell.
You shake it and nothing happens.
Whereas if you've got more room in there and then you get hit,
then you're driving the skull into the brain at a very high velocity,
which sounds bad.
I don't literally have less fluid up there.
Yeah.
And then what about with the Ivs?
Does that replace it?
It does,
but I mean you 24 hours is a pretty good period and I'm not super up on this,
but you can take somebody who's extremely dehydrated 24 hours later.
They're pretty good,
but they're still after effects.
You know,
I think you could probably find things in blood work that a week later.
like if you just shrink wrap a guy down,
like you do the usual,
you know like 20 pound weight cut that you see in a lot of these,
these fighters for like a 200 pound guy or something more,
10% or more body weight.
I bet we could see things in their blood work a week later.
Like they don't fight,
they just wait,
cut.
And then we see what,
what changes in their blood work.
I bet we could see bad stuff in their blood work a week later.
Like it leaves an impact on how do you stop people from doing it then?
I mean education led fighters think about their career holistically because the
reality is competitively there is an advantage to away.
Totally.
And I think you get as big as you can,
as lean as you can and then kind of see where that,
but then you know,
doing some field testing where you practice it,
say like you've got some sort of a,
a a,
a metabolic workout,
you know,
like whether it's pads and bags or whether it's crossfit looking thing or
something.
But you've got a standard and so you wait,
cut at a certain starting weight,
go down,
rehydrate,
do your whole,
you know,
your whole rehydration process,
see how you do on this kind of standardized workout and then maybe you gain a
little bit more weight,
a little bit more muscle if is it that much more difficult to go down and does
it actually then tank your performance?
So I think you've got to get in and do some field testing,
but it's hard to do that.
You know,
you're already trying to get ready for fight camps and do nothing else.
So yeah,
I think that's one of the things that you brought up earlier.
It's such a good point that too many fighters concentrate on conditioning
instead of concentrating on skill work at skill work.
For someone who's doing something as crazy as a combat sport,
it is the most important thing is to,
if you look at the best
guys,
they're not necessarily like Anderson Silva,
in my opinion,
is the greatest fighter that's ever lived.
And he's not the strongest guy in the world.
And he's obviously a strong guy,
but he's insanely technical,
so technical and so is it.
Everything moves fluidly.
Like he ain't never had stamina problem.
Right.
He fights deep into the fifth round and is always fun because he's a super
efficient,
super efficient.
And George St Pierre is another one and it's a fascinating thing that George
Saint Pierre does not do any strength and conditioning during his fight camps.
Right?
He says he doesn't,
doesn't believe in it.
He says he might lift the little weights,
he goes up.
But to do that to forward my look to you know,
look good,
but he's,
he's being serious.
Like everything he does is his wrestling,
kickboxing,
Jujitsu.
And when you look at the demands of that,
how much more can you do?
You know,
if you're smart and like just a little bit of,
you know,
strength or power training,
a little bit of mobility work.
But let's say you want to do some cardio,
you know,
are you as a fighter,
are you better off getting out and running?
Are you better off having somebody hold pads for you?
And you go at like 50% and you just,
you get your heart rate up a little bit,
you know,
it's like,
70,
75% of your vo two Max or whatever,
but you do a little bit of that.
You do a little bit of position positional sparring on the ground.
Do you do a little bit of clench work,
but it's all at a very controlled pace.
You need and get more out of that or out of putting on your sneakers and going
for a run.
The only thing you get good out of going for a run is,
uh,
I find running to be like a form of moving meditation.
I know,
and I think that I go over,
I go over things when I do just straight cardio work where it's forcing me in
through the monotony of evenness sitting on an elliptical machine.
Right.
You know,
it just forces me to think about stuff,
right?
Cause it's not like I'm not doing anything other than this for 30 minutes and
then see what the fuck's going on in my head.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
I think that might be a benefit to athletes because I think a lot of athletes
don't spend enough time visualizing,
spend enough time thinking about the techniques and going over things in their
head and they've,
they've shown a direct correlation between visualization and improvement in
technique that's on par with practice actually doing it.
But very few people will actually go over a whole routine in their head.
Like say if you were a wrestler and you had a series of takedowns and you put
yourself into a state of concentration where you're only thinking about your
wrestling and then all you do is concentrate on this power double over and over
again.
See yourself penetrating,
see yourself sliding off that knee,
getting your hands class together if you like really spent the time like a whole
full hour and a half of nothing but that just like you would do if you were
training nothing but that.
I think that that is a fascinating exercise to see how much it would improve a
guy maybe who's not doing that,
who's like already very good.
Right.
You know,
someone who has a hard time seeing a next plateau,
you know,
but it's a good point too.
You know,
the,
uh,
you've always got risk of injury,
even holding pads,
you know,
doing positional.
So it's actually
a good point.
Like you could sit down on the elliptical and then do some low level cardio,
but like you're not just,
you know,
you're not watching TV during that thing.
Like you're thinking through your fight strategy,
like whatever it is that's in your B game that you're trying to bring up and
you're really visualizing that and like,
you've got to think about like the feel,
the smell,
the,
you know,
you've got to visualize it as detailed as you can to get the most benefit.
But you,
you're totally spot on.
There's good stuff always dudes.
The either annoy you that you can think of when you're doing it or dudes who
you're scared of rolling with.
Like,
there's a certain dudes I know that I fucking hate rolling with.
These motherfuckers don't get tired.
Right.
You know,
they tried to kill you,
you're going to war for the next nine minutes or whatever it is,
you know.
So I always think of those motherfuckers trying to choke me lecture,
you know,
there's something that you can get out of just a straight cardio exercise.
I think mentally and physically.
Yeah,
I love doing it.
Hotel rooms.
I don't like doing this at home because it's kind of boring compared to other
shit I can do.
But I do this crazy elliptical workout.
We're all sprint for 30 seconds and then I'll relax for 30 seconds,
then I'll sprint for that and I just do as many rounds of that as I can and it's
fucking horrendous.
I don't like doing it like it's,
it's so hard to do that.
When I see one of these things at a hotel gym,
I'm like,
all right,
you mother fucker.
You know,
I get like,
I was hoping I would walk in and it just,
who'd be like a universal machine,
but if there's an elliptical machine,
we got to go to war.
I gotta do my thing.
That's what I do at every hotel that has this elliptical machine.
So it's become like this,
this battle of man versus machine,
but it's a fucking,
it's a brutal workout of just a silly little elliptical machine.
But
I mean,
you put that,
that all out effort.
Yeah.
Intervals.
What it is just crank.
You got to crank the power up,
the resistance up super high,
and you go to war for 30 seconds.
You just got to go crazy for 30 seconds and then,
and then crank that bitch back down to like eight or nine or seven or something
and relaxed.
And He'd do that for the next 30 seconds and then right back up again.
Right.
Just keep doing it.
It's terrible.
Yeah.
I think I would like doing curls on the universal machine better.
That sounds like a lot more fun.
[inaudible] university where she was so unrealistic.
Right.
It's so nonsensical.
And the bench press where it kind of turns up like that.
Right.
I remember we had those in high school and the high school wrestling around
those,
uh,
those like a fitness area,
right?
Big Universal machine.
Yeah.
This dude named frank piece could do the stack frank piece,
calendar thing.
You could do the whole stack.
It's really fucking strong kid.
Or it was like,
oh shit,
how much can you bench every day?
That was like the big question.
Right.
And they would use like universal numbers,
you know it's like 600 pounds universal or 200 pounds real.
Yeah.
It's isn't that funny.
The the,
the,
the that it's easier to push things as long as they don't have to balance them.
When you have to balance them,
end push things,
that's when shit gets slippery.
It's hard to,
hard to wrap your head around why a universal machine really wouldn't work,
but it's okay to do something on,
right.
I mean the hotel,
nothing.
Yeah,
totally.
In like you're on the road a lot just like I,
so you get,
you get done what you can get done.
Yeah.
Do you have like a hotel workout that you do?
It depends on where the place is.
Like if it's totally just nothing going on,
then I'll just do some sprints like in the stairwell and stuff like that.
And then I do some handstand pushups,
maybe some else's press to handstand and chairs doing some gymnastics stuff.
But it really depends.
There's more,
I've been hitting like double trees now because they usually have a half decent
gym and then like you can,
you can swing some dumbbells like you do with kettlebells and just get some
basic strength training in and then do some intervals on like a stair master or
an elliptical.
Yeah,
yeah.
If I don't work out when I'm on the road,
I feel twice as bad.
Right.
There's,
there's definitely something that goes on with,
uh,
when your body goes to a new place where if you do get a good workout in,
it's sort of makes everything feel okay.
Yeah.
It was sort of like a little bit of a reset.
Like if I,
if I fly into Dallas or something,
I'm like a little foggy from the trip.
If I hit the gym hard,
it just whoop,
sorta pulls you back.
Sort of levels it off.
What is,
what is going on when,
when that happens isn't just an endorphin rush from the training,
you know,
heating up your body,
it just,
Eh,
you,
you crank up all the metabolic processes going on.
So it definitely,
you know,
the endorphin rush is nice because you just feel better from that.
But whenever you heat your body up,
you are kind of accelerating all the processes in the body.
And so you're going to acclimate a little better.
They're taking some Melatonin when you travel,
you know,
that helps reset things.
But exercise has been known for a long time to help you.
If you didn't exercise and you did like,
uh,
USA to Europe travel,
it's going to take longer to get acclimated versus if you exercised every day.
Now,
when you,
um,
if you,
if you go to a place and you,
you know,
you,
you settle in and you,
uh,
you,
you do exercise and you do take Melatonin to sleep,
what is like best case scenario for you settling into a new time zone?
Like,
if someone goes from California to New York,
you know,
three times zones isn't too bad.
It'd probably be a couple of days.
If you go off,
you know,
six to nine times zones,
it's going to take a week at least.
And you're probably gonna feel pretty rough.
And if you're younger it's not going to be as bad if you're older.
I had friends that went to Australia when they came back,
they were fucked.
Yeah,
there were fuck for awhile.
They're like,
it's just like I haven't been the same and two weeks.
Man.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
And you,
you get out and exercise.
Ideally you get outside during the evening when the sun is setting that the
communication of the light into the brain kind of reset some stuff there is
really important for normal sleep.
So you should actually watch the sun turned into dark.
Ideally be outside.
Yeah.
That's what that is.
Suddenly amps are good.
Yeah.
What are the Sun Lamps?
They're like these lamps that uh,
you,
you get to that,
that simulate the sun.
Like they glow really bright like you haven't,
that you could like wake up to it.
Like it's an alarm clock on those and it really,
and they start getting brighter and brighter and brighter and you wake up with
this huge glowing light and in your bedroom
and it,
it just kind of makes you feel like a tricks your body.
Like people in Alaska have these lights all the time because of
the,
the periods of time when it's,
you know,
that,
or always daylight too.
Those are that reverse there.
Yeah.
I think it's both.
Right.
Nutty,
motherfucking place to live.
Have you ever seen the show mountain men?
Yeah.
It's a great fucking,
it's crazy.
It's my new favorite show.
That Guy Marty who lives in Alaska.
They haven't seen the show folks.
It's about three different dudes who live a one South Carolina,
once Montana,
ones,
Alaska.
The Alaska Dude flies everywhere in a plane.
If it goes for hours to be away from his family or excuse me,
months rather to be away from his family and just traps animals.
Right.
He's 24 miles on a fucking one of those.
Uh,
what are the,
what are the snowmobile,
snowmobile things?
It's craziness.
Like,
you know,
you think you got it hard.
This guy makes a living killing little animals and selling their skins three
hours by plane from his house all to escape his family probably,
right?
Yeah.
It's probably a bullshit,
right?
Yeah.
Well I've got to do what I gotta do.
Meanwhile,
he could be trapping like right next to his fucking house.
Thinking about how many goddamn animals there are in Alaska.
Why didn't have to go to the middle of nowhere and your plane?
Yeah,
he's probably up there beating off trapping squatch and it just comes over
there.
Just stack a porn.
Why?
Why is the plane so heavy this time?
I don't know.
Couldn't find anything different.
Magazines on one side and gasoline.
It's just all DVDs,
all porno DVDs,
all Asian to,
you know,
find an Asian chicks up in Alaska do very rare.
Unless they're,
unless they're,
they literally walked there from Asia on the Bering Strait,
the Inuits.
What if they have like the best Asian and we didn't even know this whole time,
new type of Asian.
It's like,
it's like their secret.
I see what you're trying to sell.
Last occasion,
Alaska.
It is weird though.
It Alaska is not attached.
That's hilarious.
Like how can you claim something that's attached to another fucking country?
You know?
Nobody wanted it.
It's kind of like us.
Some Baja not one it.
Yeah.
Why would nobody wanted,
they didn't want to get eaten.
They bought it for cheap back in the day though.
So yeah.
This dude who lives up there,
man,
this guy's a locator.
That's a crazy life.
And he does it every year.
Same thing.
Every year it was,
he was outside.
It was like 50 below zero
like you could piss and it's going to be frozen before it hits the ground.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Maybe you could not make it grow.
My pisses a lot.
It's a piss with fight it off.
You drink your own.
Do you ever drink your own piss?
I do not.
That would be a quote at the bottom of the message boards.
It would be someone's signature I bright red bed.
Do you drink piss drinks is on.
I have my own purse.
I don't do it on a regular basis.
I am part of the lunatic fringe,
but I haven't gone down that route.
So yeah,
they
taste that bad.
It's like bugs.
It's on your head.
Doesn't taste bad at all.
But I'd read some shit like a new Liotta Machita drinks his own piss does it
every morning while I'm in his father.
What's the fucking one?
Well,
mark has his famous for tricking his own past the boxer.
Yeah.
There's a,
this idea of urine therapy's supposed to like there's vitamins and nutrients
that,
that go through your body that uh,
don't get used by your body,
but they're in their past.
But they will get used if you drink your pes.
Does that sound retarded
possibility there?
Like if you,
uh,
if your wife has,
her girlfriend is pregnant,
then a hcg human chorionic gonadotropin is a hormone that stimulates like
testosterone release also.
So like he could collect their urine because the HCG is really high in the
pregnant chicks and then concentrate it down and get jacked from that.
Wow.
You get Jack
Why's pis?
Who would've thought,
fuck me.
That's where it all started from.
Dudes are smart.
They knew what the fuck was up.
Jimmy Norton Zonda some,
he's going to be all buff any day in a huge,
that's why his neck so vague.
I wonder if,
uh,
how the fuck anybody ever figured that out that you know there's any sort of
vitamins and nutrients to be had and drinking your own urine?
I don't know.
I don't use it.
It's like the core to saps.
Like why did this guy,
you know,
Caterpillar with the fungus on it.
I just think people had lower standards in the past.
Like if you don't know about hygiene and bacteria and stuff like that,
fuck yeah.
It's like why not?
Yeah.
I know for when people that take mushrooms,
that's supposed to be the end all experience is you recycle your urine while
you're tripping.
Right.
And apparently there's more silicon or psilocybin or whatever the fuck the
psychoactive ingredients is in the urine.
So as you drink it,
it's your,
it gets reabsorbed and it shoots you to the center of the universe.
Usually the,
I'm crazy,
my mushrooms,
the last thing I could do is drink or eat or it,
especially my training in your own piss.
Yeah.
I talked to a dude who did it.
He said,
you know,
everybody was telling you you've got to drink your urine.
You got it.
He was like,
I'm not tracking my fucking pissed.
I'm already high.
He goes,
I'm thinking,
I'm already tripping balls.
And he said,
so they talked me into drinking my past.
I drank it and just,
he goes,
I can't.
It was like I was pulled back in like a slingshot and when to let go to the
center of the universe.
Right.
I think just like stacking psilocybin plus Mescalin plus Lsd is probably a more
direct route to that.
Instead of light drinking.
Well,
it's supposed to be just an accelerated
version of the mushroom trip.
It's not like a confusing blend of different tricks.
The idea is just when you drink your own urine,
apparently the uh,
the,
the real experience kicks in.
It's like that takes it to the next level.
It's so trippy that it takes it to the next level.
I think I would try math first.
I'm going gonna just blow that nomadic.
The dude who did it,
the dude who did it,
I swear to God,
there's some people that come back from some,
I mean a real or imagined experience like that.
So humbled that they really are a different person and that's how this guy was.
I was like,
what happened to you?
Like,
what's going on with the like,
Yo,
you like it was the dude seemed like almost pious.
It was weird.
It was like he like was noticeably softer and tone,
noticeably more humbles.
It was,
it was weird.
I go,
what happened?
And then he tells me this whole story.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
How long ago was that?
Like to a year later he was back to himself.
When you have the full reality peel,
like when you have that complete reality peel,
it should change you a little bit.
It should.
Yeah.
It should knock your fucking socks off.
It should let you know like,
Whoa,
you might,
you might be wrong.
So,
and this might not be normal at all.
Right?
This world might be full of crazy,
magical things that can happen at any moment in time.
That's how I feel about food poisoning sometimes.
Also,
I learned a lot from food poisoning.
Yeah,
well,
you know,
Taco way ever again.
You say that,
but Sunday Sushi,
that cultures that didn't have psychedelics,
they had a rituals and rites of passages through different substances that
would,
there would be poisoned.
They'd basically like,
uh,
like a,
I think there's the name for these substances.
It's,
it's,
they're,
they're essentially toxins that don't kill you,
but you go through this ordeal poisoning,
that's what it's called.
They're called ordeal poisons.
And you go through this horrible,
horrible,
horrible experience.
And,
and when it's over,
when it passes,
you're so happy to be alive that you like,
you become nicer to people.
You become,
you.
You learned something from it.
I agree.
And so instead of having that come through the amazing and enlightening
experience of the silicide and experience,
so the mushroom trip,
instead of that,
you just almost die.
Just almost,
just the whole fucking thing falls apart on you.
Ah,
don't tell my wife about this.
She could possibly try to improve me if I recommended it.
Yeah.
You go that route.
What would she improve?
If she can improve?
You seem like a great guy.
Maybe I would cook more
homey,
like super strict with the Paleo is everybody has to follow that.
You know what I mean?
I actually do all the cooking,
so I mean,
it's like,
oh,
really.
Dot.
I do all the cooking.
And so,
I mean,
I just folks pretty much eat what I throw out there and a good gay wife.
I would,
I would
so you,
um,
uh,
always organic,
always grass fed.
You know,
we do the grass fed gig because we have a friend that owns a dairy and so we can
get grass fed me super easy and we have a big freezer from the guy who's
killing.
Aw,
that's amazing.
What a hookup.
And we get all the giblets and everything with it and stuff like that.
But if people don't respect all those giblets people don't respect Turkey,
heart,
chicken hearts and turning the hearts,
they're delicious then.
Yeah.
And the chicken hearts are fucking delicious,
man.
That's what I love about,
uh,
in Brazil,
when you go to Fogo to Shawl in Brazil that you Hoss Korea,
right?
Hey,
bring out scores of chicken hearts and everybody was like,
I'm might give him here,
bitch.
Give me fucking pussies.
Scared of.
They're delicious.
It's like a weird taste to it.
It's like chewy but not too chewy.
It's tender.
Super nutritious.
Creepy.
It's creepy.
I like that little little chicken heart.
There's a place I,
you know that place at lax,
somebody told me the restaurant that looks like at unite,
this weird futuristic forward.
Somebody told me that,
that they serve crazy food.
They're like ants and bugs and like creepy shit now.
Really?
Yeah.
Like it's just like a fear factor.
So like an international oddity sort of a ride.
I've never heard of that.
Yeah.
Somebody just told me that I don't,
I don't want you to Google that shit if find out if it's true that bad health
department scenario,
none of them have that roach.
That's a part of our festivities here where we have a,
there's a lot of countries where they do eat bugs cause I have to write.
So it's a high source of protein,
really nutritious.
But it's,
I just had a guy that sent me a cricket protein bar from Thailand.
Yo,
cricket protein.
Yeah.
So to grow these crickets,
you ate this.
It wasn't bad.
You're a bold man.
I would not think that anybody working in a fucking cricket protein bar in
Thailand would be clean and tidy.
And there was no hell shit into the batch.
Every now and again they could have,
but there was no like Hep a apparently,
like I didn't get doubled over from anything,
so nothing went wrong.
No,
not,
yeah,
it's crickets.
Why not?
You know,
it's funny,
we were,
were so weird.
We,
lobsters and lobsters have a lot of the same.
They're just a water cricket.
It's a water roach.
Giant Roche.
Yeah,
it's,
it actually,
if you eat roaches,
it's the,
if you are allergic to shellfish,
you'll eat roaches,
you'll get fucked up.
We learned that on fear factor the hard way.
The dude had a shellfish allergy and he had eight roaches and,
uh,
MP pen.
Yeah.
He had a,
he had to get jacked with,
what is it?
Adrenaline.
They shoot you with epinephrine or adrenaline.
Here's this thing called throat was closing in.
Here's the thing they caught,
it's called typhoon,
I guess.
Uh,
Taiwan.
It's crickets,
crickets,
amphibian,
Scorpions,
larvae.
But they also have empanadas frog legs,
Filipino.
Some variety.
Yeah.
It seems like they're just trying to go like super international look,
New Zealand,
New Zealand food,
Filipino food.
It looks like it looks Yummy,
man.
That makes me a Jay,
do you,
do you have a hard time with your,
your diet going to restaurants?
Not really.
I mean like,
like the,
uh,
Brazilian barbecue is a perfect example.
They've always got tons of meat,
fruit,
veggies.
I mean,
it's usually pretty easy.
We have those places are so healthy.
Yeah.
We spent two weeks in Florence,
Italy,
and it wasn't hard to eat this way.
I mean,
there's always a chunk of meat.
There's always like some veggies,
so it's not that bad.
It's pretty easy.
You a totally avoid pastas.
Grains yet,
like I'll have a little bit of corn,
like some corn Tortillas,
but uh,
yeah,
like any wheat containing item.
Like if I had some wheat
in your bathroom out there would be blue commission.
Like a,
a Zq Pasta.
No,
no.
Like it's still like the sprouted grains reduce the problematic proteins that
cause the inflammation in the gut,
but they're not totally gone.
So like,
you know,
someone like you,
you might be a little more resistant to it and you,
you know,
like if you had say like whole wheat pasta,
we might see some problems.
You have the as eeky old type Pasta,
it,
you don't really see the problems.
Whereas for me,
I would still have some problems with it.
So I'm kind of like the canary in the coal mine with it.
Yeah.
I like [inaudible] Ezekiel Pasta if you've never had it folks.
It's a,
um,
it's a sprouted grain.
They make bread Ezekiel bread and it's a really,
it's based on how it says to make bread in the Bible apparently,
or just kind of trip it,
you know,
the super healthy grains and legumes,
if you eat them without sprouting,
like they literally can make you sick.
Like if you just took them uncooked and Aidan.
Yeah.
It would make you,
and nobody ever like just eats wheat.
Right.
And,
and that's why like it literally would make you sick.
Did they ever figure out how to eat it?
How long were you desperate?
Where people,
I don't know,
but I mean,
you know,
how do you figure out to,
to like stick it in a bucket of water,
let it sprout and start smelling a little bit fermented and then start eating
it.
Like,
I don't know.
How do you ever eat a coconut?
Have you ever eaten a lobster?
Well,
lobsters,
I could see giving it a shot man and some bugs.
Anything with a face.
It's kind of like,
just don't eat the business end of it.
And you're pretty good.
Yeah.
Whichever in that may be.
So it depends on which business you're talking about it.
Yes.
So think about
by an actual Vegan Diet like the China study and you know,
things along those lines where people have been advocating a completely
vegetable based diet.
Is that,
is that
[inaudible]?
I think it's an improvement off the standard American diet.
Like typically people are eating more fruit,
more veggies are more conscious about the stuff that they're reading.
I just don't see people thriving on that long term.
And what is the problem?
They don't get enough protein.
They don't get enough B vitamins.
Excuse me.
Crazy Vegan people.
I love you.
Well,
you get a little crazy,
but they do have a point in that there are some plants that have a full amino
acid spectrum,
right?
They have,
they have all the amino acids is
full protein.
You can,
you can stay alive.
You just don't one of those,
yeah,
I call them third world proteins.
Like you'll survive,
but you won't thrive.
Like what is the difference between them and what you get from meat?
You just get such a concentrated source of proteins from me.
And on a hormonal level,
you're releasing insulin and Glucagon when you eat protein and that that is
really beneficial for energy levels,
for muscle mass.
I mean when you,
when you look at most of the Vegan athletes,
particularly in the kind of body building and strength seen,
they're always using like some sort of protein concentrate,
like a rice protein concentrate or something.
They're not just eating beans,
rice keen.
While they're not really eating whole foods,
they're still a concentrated proteins or they,
I mean they just fail miserably when they do that.
When they do eat the concentrate of protein source,
is that sufficient?
I,
it'll,
it'll work.
But you,
you know,
it's like to eat the concentrated protein from a cow or from brown rice and hemp
protein and,
and for me it's like I just do the cow because it works better.
It tastes better.
It works better.
Yeah.
It just works better.
And this is
when you say,
I'm sorry to as,
because my vegan friends would go crazy if I didn't.
When you say it works better,
have there been studies where they have shown a decrease in physical performance
because of following a Vegan diet
as opposed to an or or an increase in,
in a meeting diet?
I mean,
has there ever been any study done
studies comparing vegetarian diets to mixed diets and typically the performance
and not as good.
So I mean there is some,
the only way they would really tell right is to like get an athlete,
put them on it,
see what their performance is,
get that same athlete,
put them on this other diets and then isn't that sort of bio specific to that
one individual?
Yeah.
And you know,
like a Carl Lewis is,
is kind of carried around is,
is a Vegan success.
He had one year of uh,
of good performance and then his performance tanked after that.
And it was during a time that you would reasonably assume that he,
you know,
kind of like,
Ooh,
St Bolt,
that he should continue to improve.
Right.
And so that,
that's where like you take somebody eating a standard American diet that's super
proinflammatory.
It's tons of refined foods and everything.
You put him on a Vegan Diet,
I think they're probably going to look,
feel and perform better.
Like there's no doubt about that down the road.
I just don't see people doing as well.
And,
and you know,
it's not like you need to eat,
uh,
boatloads of meat to round out,
you know,
like say you take this Vegan Diet that I would still put like Paleo carbs in it
instead of,
uh,
beans,
rice keen won stuff.
I would have yams,
sweet potatoes,
fruits,
veggies,
which still have more vitamins,
minerals and antioxidants per calorie.
So you're still good there.
And then if you throw in a little bit of eggs,
a little bit of finish,
a little bit of meat,
like you're getting a ton of nutrition from that,
you're going to build muscle,
you're going to recover well.
And it doesn't need to be like the whole part of the Diet.
That's where like the individual,
you know,
specifics,
dialing this stuff in could really work.
But
in eggs for folks who don't know,
cause I didn't even know this until I was in my thirties which is very sad.
But eggs,
you don't kill anything to get an egg.
The chicken lays an egg every night.
It's not like if you have like a moral sort of a quandary.
Yeah.
Quandary about eating animals and killing animals,
that's okay.
But chicken,
eggs,
like you don't have to be,
you don't have to fertilize those eggs.
They pop out every day.
Everybody's fine.
Eat the egg.
No one dies,
you
know,
on,
on the moral side.
And I will probably have the vegans come and kill me if anybody ever comes and
kills me.
It's either going to be militant Vegan or a religious fanatic.
And those people will track me down at my house and kill me and probably
decorate their house with my intestines or something.
But yeah,
that's,
you just gave them a pretty picture is you're taking their pants off right now.
Oh,
make it so,
but there was this professor that did an economic analysis of meeting versus not
mediating and this whole kind of moralistic stance.
And they call it the least harm principle.
Like what could you do with regards to the food supply that's going to kill the
fewest animals and the vegans kind of paint this picture that if I eat beans and
rice and and chemo on stuff,
that is somehow a bloodless affair,
but tons of animals are killed in the process of farming.
You know,
and and so you mean like small animals?
All animals?
Yeah.
Yes.
Snakes and birds.
And just the fact that the way that we do mega farming,
you destroy whole ecosystems to do that.
Where it's like there's this Guy Joel Salitan who has the Polyface farms and
they do biodynamic farming where you've got pigs and chickens and it's outside
and they use solar power that that farm produces more food,
more,
more nutrition per acre than any of farm on the planet.
Where is this,
where they did a New Hampshire,
I think Polyface farms.
Joel Salitan.
Cool Dude.
And what has you have it set up?
He has it set up so the cattle will go through and graze on grass,
which is what they're designed to do to eat.
They're not designed to eat grains and you don't have to put any oil into
producing grass like you need to produce grains,
you know?
So there's that whole thing.
Then after the cattle go through and they put up a,
a solar powered electric fences to move these critters around.
Sorry,
what do you eat oil to produce grains.
What?
Yeah,
what do you mean?
Like all of the farm machinery and all the infrastructure too,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's a hugely intensive versus,
yeah.
Yeah.
Or,
or even say like fruit and nut trees.
Like they're relatively start feeding them grains.
Uh,
early 1970s,
there were some fluctuations in food prices and there was a desire on the part
of the US government,
I think it was right at the end of Nixon's scene,
they started dumping a bunch of subsidy money into intensifying farm production
of basically like corn and soybeans and stuff like that.
And they wanted to create an export commodity out of that.
And when we started producing all of this,
this,
uh,
grain like high carbohydrate stuff,
we needed to do something with it,
which is where we then started,
you know,
recommending it via things like the food pyramid that you need to eat,
12 servings of whole grain today and stuff like that.
So it was a,
a government sponsored move,
which I'm just totally a nutcase libertarian,
like I guess can't fucking stand the government coming in and,
and subsidizing any industry because you end up destroying the market forces
that would normally control it.
So now we have a twinkie that costs less than an apple,
but it really doesn't cost less because we're paying for the subsidized
production of that food via taxes and via going and acquiring oil and all these
other indirect methods.
So if you,
you had kind of decentralized farming and you have something that looks like the
Polyface farms where they grow cattle and horses and pigs,
and it's all kind of a self contained nutrient cycles.
So the cattle go through and then the chickens go through and move the,
you know,
the cow poop around.
And then you've got all these talks and live like that.
I've always thought that that would be such a cool fucking thing to be able to
buy a farm somewhere and actually have it set up like that where you'd get all
your food from the ground.
That would be fucking amazing.
So it sounds like a pain in the Dick though.
That's your life.
Be Labor intensive.
Your Life.
Forget about Jujitsu class.
I forget about playing pool.
You gotta milk some counts.
Get your kids involved.
The kids going to have to start working right out far.
I want my kids to work on a farm.
Right.
Throwing Hay and shit.
Then a tornado comes,
carries a little joeys Brian Farms on are always where tornadoes are.
You could have a farm in California,
but I guess they do have tornadoes in California.
They spotted a little one recently up around Chico.
Yeah.
I'm shit shit could go down anywhere.
Those whole thing is a big fat,
crazy mess that could all fall apart.
The,
um,
the idea of this Paleo Diet is a,
to me the most,
it like instantly when I heard about it,
I was like,
oh yeah,
that makes sense.
You know,
I,
you know,
I follow it.
I tried the Atkins for a little while and I swear to God,
it was like,
it was one of the worst I've ever felt.
Right.
You know,
I don't know.
I think eaten too much gas.
Horrible man.
My ex girlfriend used to do that and it really kind of pissed me off because it,
it,
it was not healthy at all.
Just watching her sit there only eating cheese everyday and bacon fat.
I'm just like,
come on.
I,
I'm more of a weight watchers person,
but,
so to me it's like you just need to have a little bit of everything.
But a good part of the Atkins died to me was that you could eat meat and you can
eat as much vegetables as you want it to.
Right.
There really is.
Yeah.
And if you have somebody who's like type two diabetic,
they would benefit a lot from something that looks like an Atkins Diet.
Like type two diabetes is 100% it's reversible in that you can take somebody
who's not managing their blood glucose and the Rondo host of drugs and they're
very likely to die from like a heart attack,
stroke,
cancer,
and if you feed them a ketogenic,
like a moderate protein,
high fat diet,
you can shift their body's metabolism to run on ketones and they're going to
live amazingly well and they're not going to,
they're not going to bankrupt,
you know,
society because we're spending a bunch of money trying to manage this stuff.
But for an athlete,
for somebody who's not metabolically broken,
I just like to steer people more towards like,
you know,
fruits,
veggies,
yams,
sweet potatoes,
stuff,
dad for the carbs.
When you carb load though,
do you get the same carb load from fruits and veggies that you would if you were
eating a giant plate of Pasta,
that's where you use
Yammer or a sweet potato or something like that and it's very,
you know,
it's like a one for wine kind of.
Yeah,
same thing.
Yeah.
The Am's are fucking delicious too.
Wow.
If I were to go for a yam or a plate of Spaghetti,
I'm going to take that spaghetti.
Yeah.
Cause its Yummier and I feel like I'm getting away with something when I eat it.
You know the uh,
the has
some opiate like chemicals in it that,
that stimulate the addiction centers in the brain.
Better does Lasagna.
That's like heroin.
It's very similar.
Lasagna when you're eating you're like,
aw shit.
It's like some real low level heroin.
God Damn.
I've become addicted to trying to find the best Mac and cheese I've ever,
every time I go to our restaurant and I'm like damn it,
they have one here.
I have to get it,
you know,
have to sterilize this mother fucker's the worst diet of all time.
I don't have a bad diet.
I just eat macaroni and cheese.
How could that go wrong?
Eating once a day.
Yeah.
I just eat once a day.
At least two hours in his car.
How could any of that go wrong?
Not going to go right.
It's not going to go right.
Yeah.
Um,
have you ever thought about like,
uh,
like working with a big name MMA guys and getting,
getting together with some,
uh,
high level fighters and organizing their food and their camps?
Would love to,
like I've done some consulting for like frank and for forest and stuff like
that.
Frank went from a Vegan Diet,
I should explain to your diet and had much better results.
He said,
he said he just really felt listless when he was on a Vegan diet and he said,
I think it was really nice.
He was joking around about it.
He was probably doing it wrong because a,
it was eating so much carbs that is like blood sugar just jacked through the
roof.
And he was a having an insulin issues,
eating pasta all the time.
And,
and you see that a lot with folks.
And so I think,
you know,
if you have a,
somebody eating Vegan and they're doing more like yams,
sweet potatoes,
fruits for their carbs and they're probably gonna do better.
But I just don't see people thrive on it.
But yeah,
that would Danzig fights.
He's a Vegan and he does well.
Does it very well.
It was a very skilled guy and he's been a vegan forever.
He does a rice protein.
That's his,
uh,
what he did at least last time I discussed it with him.
But yeah,
he's a very strict Vegan.
Yeah.
And it,
you know,
there's also a piece to like the elite athletes seen that there's sometimes not
the best people to look to for what everybody should be doing.
Beans.
I mean,
there are guys out there that can eat anything and still succeed.
So it's uh,
you know,
it's just something to tinker with,
uh,
get in and try Vegan for a month.
See how you do,
try Paleo for months.
Yeah.
You do.
And see which one works for you.
Let me tell you about my retarded theory.
I think that things that are hard to catch or better for you and that's why I
think dear is so good for you and elk.
There's a reason why they're running so fast.
Try to get the fuck away.
It's because they is set it up so they're hard to get.
Exactly.
Fish nature set up so they're really hard to catch.
Whereas like cow,
she could walk right up to account,
shoot it in the fucking head and the other cows in here,
the other car was near it.
We were like,
what happened?
And they'll just keep beating the grass.
Charlie's gone.
Yeah,
they're stupid.
But even though the delicious,
it's not as good for you as say elk is like elk is hard to get.
It's hard to get an elk.
Right.
You know they're out there running around.
That's a,
that's a real motherfucker out there living in the wild and you got to go jack
him almost Vigo fully cave man.
If you've got like a hand thrown sphere,
then you might end up on the business end of,
yeah.
Well do you know that people are actually doing that now?
That is the latest wave and hunting is spear hunting.
Yeah,
he booked trying to spear deers and shit.
Good fucking luck.
You lucky that's recreational motherfucker.
You're going to starve to death there.
There's some youtube video of me killing a 650 pound elk with a hand thrown
spirit.
Holy Shit.
We,
we did a [inaudible] this video,
we'll,
that shit.
There was a discovery channel show called [inaudible] cave man.
Wow.
You got trained as caveman and,
and did the shit for,
for like 10 days.
And where is the show if discovery channel?
A curiosity series.
What is it on still?
It's still on.
Yeah.
It's silly.
There's a new show or is it,
it was last year.
Oh,
so it was like a one off one,
one episode.
That should be a damn series discovery channel.
That would be fucking awesome.
It was like they had another one,
like a Morgan Spurlock hosted the one that we were on and Robin Williams did a
show on drug use and so they would get people whacked on just a variety of drugs
and do like a pet scans on their brain to see what was firing and everything.
Yeah.
And funny enough,
the Dude Robert who was on the show with me for I cave man,
he ended up getting picked for the,
uh,
the,
the drug show.
He has a sorted past.
So it was pretty cool.
I would think that a show where people would be forced to actually live like a
caveman would be fascinating to make your own spears and try to make it your own
bows and arrows and you know,
do you,
you got nothing man.
You're just naked,
right?
And then when you want to tap out,
you let us know and you can tap out and you can come back to civilization.
They gave us clothes,
but we had to learn how to make our own fire,
make our own tools.
And there was this guy Billy who was a primitive skills expert and he could
take,
uh,
you know,
big rock start whacking it and then have like a stone knife and like five
minutes.
He was amazing.
W I wonder if we could have a show like that where there's a big prize and it's
like they,
they have to see like who can live the longest as a caveman?
And if you could do it,
you get like something crazy,
like 5 million bucks.
I've had this idea of like the,
you know,
the weight loss show,
but it,
so you've got people that are living this kind of caveman esque lifestyle.
They work out and the Paleo and you know,
they get put through challenges and stuff,
but instead of like the punishment would actually be giving them westernized
refined food,
not letting them sleep,
making them stay up late and play video games.
So basically the punishment would be living the westernized lifestyle because it
ultimately say like you have like $1 million prize or something and it's all
based on like body composition change or weight loss or something.
But if you give them the only food to eat shitty food and you keep them awake
and you don't let them exercise and they're not going to lose body weight,
that's a great idea.
So the punishment is actually living modern life and the only way that you could
win,
like the people who do it best,
the way that they win is by actually avoiding the modern scenario.
So if,
if you can figure out some way to get that thing,
we'll have people who work out hard and then they get to a certain,
is that it?
That's it.
They show you killing it.
Yeah.
If you back up a little bit,
you can see me hugging the,
it's
called an Atlatl a little bit more because I think so.
It depends on,
yeah,
I know.
I guess more bring it all to the beginning.
This is a,
this is like a teaser.
I think.
Maybe it's not in that one in.
And if you do this one where somebody recorded the TV.
Yeah.
This will actually show the throw dude.
Holy Shit.
So that's me with the helmet cam in the outlaws.
Wow.
We finally right.
Good locations.
So this is on day eight.
We've had no food at all for eight days.
I lost 18 pounds.
Oh my God.
So you already did this.
You already live later cave man.
This is crazy.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
It was something else.
And Bill,
he's in perfect position.
So this is the guy that's a primitive skills experts.
Super Cool Dude.
But unfortunately he ministers to bring home some meat.
Rob Is our last chance.
The rest of us are just too far away and these elk can spook at any mall.
It's getting ready to throw in that little dark and I was waiting for the cell
to turn it so that I have the flank in the neck,
although men to be ready time just was stopped if felt like the beginning of the
world and the end of the world and everything's all woven together.
Got once you got one,
we got one,
I got into gym and I could just see it rifle and get DLC in the neck.
The tail end of the dark whipped around and that,
oh shit,
sorry.
Kill Shot.
Wow.
The Hertz.
So I'm a total coward.
Jordan.
I knew what we were going to be getting into doing this gig and so I started,
I made my own that level at home like a month early and I'd spend like explain
that.
What is it called?
It's a spear throwing device.
It's got a base.
If you've ever seen highligh where you,
you know,
you throw the ball,
so you've got this,
this base that gives you some leverage and then you've got a long flexible dark
that looks like a really flexible uh,
arrow,
but it's six feet long stone tip on the front and the things,
what's the show where they,
the warrior versus warrior or whatever,
like ultimate ultimate.
I was the one that knows the ultimate warrior,
is it?
No,
it's the one that wasn't it the one?
no,
no.
That was the human weapon.
But,
but they,
they checked out an Atlatl on that show and it has as much power as a to 73
round because of the weight and the velocity you're able to leverage from
swinging that thing.
How accurate is it?
Not very accurate.
So you can just,
I practiced or did you actually aimed for that one?
I ain't for a shoulder and then it went a little high and actually it was a
better shot than what I was aiming for.
You must have been stoked.
It was pretty amazing because I hadn't eaten anything.
And eight days the fuck did you survive after not eating anything for eight
days?
Dude,
you uh,
I lost 18 pounds.
One thing.
So you run off your body fat,
have the strike to throw that thing?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean when we had to,
we had three more days to go to wrap up the experiment and I like,
I did not want to quit and,
but I,
it was miserable.
It was cold that was outside of steamboat springs in Colorado and the nighttime
temperature was like 28 degrees and you're sleeping more,
sleeping outside on the ground.
But we had like a hut that we had built and stuff like that.
But it was fucking cold starting any fires.
Yeah.
We made a fire.
Like we had to make a fire with a,
you know,
a hand drill and all
Jesus Christ.
So what,
how come you guys couldn't find anything to eat for eight days?
Well,
they stuck us up in the mountains because it was beautiful and there was no
food.
Like all of the anthropologists were on the show were like,
yeah,
all the native Americans in this area would be 5,000 feet further down the
mountain.
We were at almost 9,000 feet up the mountain up there.
There's nothing there.
And it was shot in June.
Yeah.
In June.
At 9,000 feet.
It gets 28 degrees at night.
Yeah.
Mother fucker.
It snowed on us the first night that we were there.
Oh God.
And June.
Yeah.
Wow,
dude.
It's not la
killed a fucking elk with a spear.
Odd waddle or whatever the hell it is.
This model,
the model.
That's amazing,
man.
It was pretty cool.
That is pretty cool.
Elkert incredible animals,
man.
Yeah.
When I went to evergreen,
there's this crazy photo of a,
the town of immigrant is beautiful.
You ever been there?
Yeah.
The full town up in the mountains above Denver,
and there's,
um,
there's this photo and the town's website,
whether it's like,
I don't know,
a hundred elk walking right down the middle of their mainstream,
completely blocking traffic.
It's like,
Holy Shit.
Like what a cool little piece of nature that these delicious animals wander
through your whole town and by the hundreds,
you know,
and then make their way through the forest.
There's something fucking magical about that,
man.
I mean,
it sucks a big fat dick when it snows up there.
Your car is sliding around on the mountain roads and all that.
That's all terrible.
But man,
that just the majestic beauty of being in front of a herd of elk and watch them
walk across the street,
it's like,
wow.
Yeah,
those animals were amazing.
Like they were totally amazing to behold night.
Like when we were out there,
they would spook and then run away from us,
but some of the bowls would turn around and it was kind of like,
that guy is smaller than I.
Yeah.
Like I said,
are you serious?
Apparently we're not used to hunter's.
Otherwise they would have run.
Yep.
Well,
you know where that spot was.
We were coming up a hill and the sun was coming up behind us and the wind was
blowing over the elk,
so they couldn't see us yet.
Really?
Like the sun literally was in their eyes.
So that was part of the reason why we succeeded that day.
And then also because it was day eight and we had failed all the other days.
We only had two camera crew and they were set up like 400 yards away,
kind of triangulated in on where we were to get a decent shot.
So the only local camera we had was on my head.
And that's part of the reason why we succeeded to usually we had like six camera
guys stomping through block
in the fleet.
Yeah,
yeah.
Ridiculous.
That's not going to work.
So how many different times did you actually throw that thing and an elk?
I only got two shots off.
So the first one went high,
which they didn't show in that.
And then my second one hit it same day.
Yeah.
So there was no time during the other eight days.
We got a shot,
not me,
not me.
Other people went out and had shots,
but I never,
I never gotten a position where I,
so no one found any food for the eight days.
Are Some folks like dandelions?
Um,
we,
we had lake for trout one day divided up around among 10 people.
Uh,
so I mean not,
she's not a lot.
Yeah.
There was a mouse.
You eat the eight a mouse.
Oh,
what the fuck man?
I cooked it really well just in case.
It was like dangit fever in it or something.
Yeah.
Fucking mouse.
What is a mouse?
Tastes like,
uh,
will.
Yeah.
It didn't taste good.
I don't know.
An analogous tasted,
it just wasn't good.
I mean it was burnt and you're eating the intestines and you know,
you're crunching through the skull.
It's too small to gut,
so you just cook it really well and you just start on the front end and finished
with a tail end.
Shit.
Yeah.
You just shoot it down.
Bones and all
mice are pretty fast.
I guess that kills that.
Oh my God.
Have you,
uh,
what is that crazy dish that it's a famous dish where they take little birds and
they drown them and brandy or the lawn,
what is it called?
I've never heard of.
I have the,
yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
My crazy friend Duncan turned me on to this.
He claims that I turned in the him onto it,
but I think he's crazy.
Um,
but the idea is that they would,
uh,
take these birds and it was like some weird,
ridiculous delicacy where they would eat it or it,
alon,
this is what it is.
A rite of passage for French Gore maize has been eating of the order on these
tiny birds captured alive force fed and then drowned in our mug.
Armagnac I guess it's the type of cognac or something like that were roasted
hole and eaten that way.
Bones and all while the diner draped his head with a linen Napkin to preserve
the precious aromas and some believe to hide from God.
Whoa.
Sorry.
Barbaric.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
That's a weird way to eat an animal.
I mean,
how did they figure out how to make a delicious over feed it and then drown it
in,
in the burbs and booze?
What a weird animal.
It sounds like a mafia hit.
Well,
the idea is you wear a hood over your head while you eat it to get the aromas.
Like,
Whoa,
that's fucked.
That's just fucking weird.
Leave it.
Is that the French?
Of course.
Yeah.
Naturally the creepy one of those crazy ideas about drowning birds,
don't they make Flog Raul?
So which is force feeding.
Delicious.
Yeah.
More.
But that shit's
really good,
right?
Yeah.
It's illegal now in California,
right?
You can bring your own flog raw to the restaurant and they'll cook it for you.
Oh really?
They can't buy it.
Yeah.
That's so silly.
So now you've,
which is another one,
these market deals.
So you took something that was regulated,
people kept track of it.
There was some standards and some hygiene.
And so now you've driven it into a black market deal where black market,
and by the way,
it's not like they're running out of goose.
We're trying to protect the goose.
You can kill the fucking shit out of goose.
Right?
He's,
you can kill them all day long and nobody cares.
You just can't inflame their livers.
Right where he killed them.
You have to be nice to them.
Meanwhile,
if you ever see like one of those feeding tubes where they force feed them,
they hang out near that.
They want to get force fed.
Like if they don't have Gagic instincts,
they just know when that thing goes in their mouth and their full right.
You know,
we're just,
we're so,
so weird with our,
what we allow,
what we don't like.
You still allow veal,
like veal seems to me way crueler than a couple of seconds getting forced fed
with some grain.
No,
veal is a tricky thing or just jersey shore.
So,
yeah,
I mean that seems inhumane to so what do you do if you do eat veal?
I,
if it's there,
I do.
But I mean it's not,
it's not something you ever think about how creepy it is.
It's pretty creepy.
Just like,
I mean it's like Coby beef,
you know,
it's all rubbed and massage and you know,
uh,
milk fed and everything and Colby fit.
Kobe beef is like,
don't they feed it alcohol at this Joe Penis?
Oh,
well that's,
that's so crazy.
What they're like connecting human beings to animals,
like force feeding it.
And it's always quite high sexual kind of thing going on.
I look,
she's got like,
her lipstick is running and they're so silly.
They're like all extremists,
they're silly.
It's,
you know.
Yup.
And one of them will probably kill me some day.
So because you killed that elk with,
uh,
with,
even more so now get hate mail after you did that.
Not Hate Mail,
but there was some hate tweeting and a,
yeah.
And there was a set of,
you know,
yeah.
And there was a woman who was at that,
people are upset.
I mean,
while they're probably meat eaters,
you know,
the funny thing is there was a woman who was a cartoonist who is a mediator,
but thought that it was appalling that I hunted in animal.
And I was Kinda like,
okay.
So it's not like I was sitting,
you know,
a quarter mile away with a sniper scope.
Like I was out on my feet.
This animal could have stomped me into a bloody mess too.
So it's about as equal an exchange as you're going to get doubts,
some real shit.
You went to war with an animal with some shit you made,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
No,
I think you win.
I think that lady can shut her fucking hole.
Shut your hole lady silly next Tuesday.
It's so dumb.
If you eat meat,
if you actually eat me,
would you prefer the or pig to be stuffed into some fucking crazy container and
live its life and its own shit until it finally gets slaughtered?
You know?
Is that,
is that somehow or another better play?
Some role and yeah,
it's so weird the,
we're the strangest
animal with this anti hunting,
but pro meet thing,
right?
It's like you not going to stop people from eating me.
You could go crazy pita all you want.
You go crazy Vegan all you want for a lot of people that's blah,
blah,
blah.
In and out as delicious.
You know like barbecue is too fucking good taste too.
God damn good.
A real good ribeye.
Medium rare over mesquite calls.
Shut your fucking mouth with your keen Wa.
It's not as good.
I'm sorry.
It's just not,
it's not and that's why they're,
the vegans are always trying to make fake meat.
Yeah,
they're silly.
So fake chicken and Chili that the Tofurky.
The thing about it is like,
yeah,
it seems like we should evolve past that.
It seems like we shouldn't be about cruelty and we seems like we shouldn't be,
but what is,
what is the least cruel thing?
Lee's cruel thing is to have an animal live its whole life completely wild and
free.
They'd take it out with a bullet,
right,
and then no,
it doesn't know what the fuck is going on.
It just hears a,
a branch snap and Stein one through the heart and that's a wrap son.
I mean that's a,
that's a quick death.
That is a lot better than a cow living on a farm.
Yet people have a problem with people hunting and they don't have a problem
eating at Burger King.
Right.
That's,
that is strange.
People were strange.
We get really weird one.
Once we got agriculture and we've got the ability to have a surplus and we got
the ability to store things.
Yeah.
I mean it starts,
I think when you were still running farms,
you were still tied into food because you had to go out and kill your food.
And like you,
you know,
there was a little more tied to it.
But,
um,
you know,
when you walk into a grocery store and kids really don't understand that plants
grow in the dirt,
you know,
that,
that corner,
you know,
an apple or whatever grew from a plant that's in the dirt.
They don't even realize that.
And then when you go to the meet deal and you understand what's involved with
killing and processing an animal,
like it's pretty gruesome shit.
You know,
it's no joke.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's no joke.
Do we have to be concerned with the lack of minerals in the top soil?
You know,
I've,
I've read,
uh,
people have,
discussed whether or not it's healthy to be trying to replenish them with
chemicals and whether or not they're supposed to be like a natural cycle of like
leaving certain areas alone for awhile and then planting them in the future.
Could I answer that after taking a leak?
Yeah.
I saw you turning.
I,
I saw him go through that door and uh,
the last door on the left notice ladies and gentlemen,
how strong my bladder is.
Yeah.
It's not good for you to have a strong bottle.
I used to hold it all the time.
Now I tried to go and needs the second I feel like,
oh,
I might have to pee.
I tried to go because I used to hold it for long periods of time,
but my bladder,
it doesn't hurt me now,
but it doesn't bother me if he could,
if he do that over time,
you're going to have hard time holding your pen when you get older.
Yeah.
Dude,
when I have a hard time holding my pee and quick here,
I'm not down with that.
But I don't,
I don't agree with that.
I think,
you know,
it's silly.
No,
I see.
Never heard that before.
No.
If it bothered me a lot,
I would go pee.
Yeah.
But it's not really,
I can just hold it longer.
I drink a lot of water too.
Maybe it's,
I'm used to it.
Maybe have a more stretched out bladder.
No,
I mean I could totally just could never pee all day.
I could be once a day if I wanted to.
I think only once a day.
I used to hold my pee a lot cause I had jobs that I worked at Louis C K at a
funny bit.
You Ever Hold Your pee because you're just so bored.
He wants to concentrate on something.
I forget the actual joke,
but it's so true.
So bored to just wholly and your P
pan.
Tomorrow's a podcast with uh,
Maynard is going to be ridiculous to me.
I wonder if he's going to bring some of those wine.
I want to try it.
I find that amazing.
I think that is just one of the most
original things that are our rock stars ever done.
You know,
call him a rock star musician.
Artist just decides to become a winemaker.
I think that's amazing.
I'm really,
I love the idea behind it.
Just hides it,
you know,
but growing it on his own farm,
it's a small operation.
They grow the grapes,
the whole thing,
the whole process.
I think that's amazing man.
I'm really,
really interested with,
I don't know if I talked about this,
about a Francis Ford Coppola's daughter Sophie Sophie's Copa.
Her wine company is pretty cool what she's doing with it.
She's doing something that,
uh,
that I think is pretty unique and I,
I'm actually,
um,
I'm on board 100%.
He,
uh,
she's sewing little portable wine in cans,
like cake pop cans and they're like,
like the small cokes if you're by the smoke coke cans,
they're like a Gnat or that she has this other one where it's like this little
little wine glass that just has a peel off a thing and it has like a resealable
lid for it and it's just like completely like the opposite of what you're
supposed to drink wine and he's supposed to be and get the high end like wine.
It's like a new version of portable box wines and her father Francis Ford
Coppola,
doesn't he have a vineyard?
It's like a very famous vineyard.
That's where she,
she's doing her own thing.
I don't know if it's at the same vineyard or not,
but that's kind of,
that's kind of smart.
But she does everything.
Her Dad.
Yeah,
that
does.
That's a good mood.
And Your Dad's Francis Ford motherfucking Coppola and you can do whatever you
want.
Yeah.
I want to make some portable wine bitch.
When you look at the economy and everything,
I mean instead of driving towards the top end,
then you make some cheap,
you know,
box wine style stuff,
but then a different delivery deal.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
For a lot of people there's not that much difference between the $30 bottle of
wine,
a $5 bottle of wine.
Right.
You know,
especially after the first bottle.
So yeah,
especially at the first few sips.
If you're a Somalia and you're hammered,
you don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Let's be honest.
How bad his alcohol for you?
Uh,
I mean it poisons all into the dose.
So I mean,
I have a couple of drinks a day and,
and you know,
not too bad and I stick more with like nor Margarita is just like Tequila.
Couple drinks every day.
Yeah.
You really,
you're an animal.
You don't give a fuck.
It's wild.
It's crazy.
Health and nutrition.
He drinking a two drinks a day probably.
Yeah.
Yeah,
one to two.
Yeah.
But it's no big deal.
I don't think that that's all that big a deal.
If I was in training camp for something,
then I would ditch it.
Obviously,
you know,
you need to tighten stuff up,
but if you're doing,
you know,
six,
eight drinks a night or you know,
multiple times a week,
obviously that's a problem.
So I mean it's just kind of a dose response curve,
you know,
if you're on that,
if you're a a dude,
then you can probably get away with a drink or two a day and it's,
it probably helpful in the long run.
But um,
for,
for a female,
a little bit less than that,
but how is it helpful?
Is it helpful because you're relax gives you have the drink.
I said helpful.
Is there anything in,
I think it's that stuff,
you know,
you relax.
There's usually some socialization that goes on.
Uh,
there's some stuff in the alcohol.
It's interesting like just being exposed to a stress.
There's this process called hormesis where like when you exercise,
you get some damage to the muscles or to the cardiovascular system and your body
needs to adapt to that.
And it's actually the process of adapting that's good for you and alcohol causes
some damage to the body that then it needs to respond to and there's some kind
of beneficial elements to that.
I had a crazy idea when I was younger.
It's a stupid idea,
but it was like if you smoke cigarettes,
maybe they make your lung stronger.
Who they have to fight off the cigarette smoke.
I really did this,
I to quit when you're about 40.
When I was wrestling,
one of the best kids on our wrestling team was a smoker and I always worried
about that.
That's Sophia's little one kind of selling it,
you know,
like a can of beer,
like a hand job.
All you're saying is her hand in the water.
You're thinking slippery.
Why are we outside?
You're jerking me off.
Stop.
You shouldn't do this is your dad's house.
She can't afford Francis Ford Coppola's house.
No less.
So he says Christ people are watching.
It must be cameras.
Yeah.
Um,
so one or two drinks a day.
No problem.
Yeah.
And I would steer low right now
because no one ever hears that.
Everyone here is alcohol is terrible for you and it's not,
I mean they,
you know,
they tried to demonize a lot of stuff,
whether it's red meat or booze or whatever,
like because um,
you know,
like the gluten free deal and I love beer,
but beer is loaded with gluten,
so like can you do that?
So I don't drink beer.
Margarita Margarita is,
and I've been doing site or like after we spent some time in northern Europe,
like they do some amazing siders.
So I do some of that stuff.
So I'm wondering if it's,
I get a real weird heavy feeling from beer that I don't get from other things
when I want to have a,
a couple of glasses of whiskey,
I get it little,
I get drunk but I don't get deli.
The bloat.
Yeah.
You never drink light beers though.
You always drink like the Heineken Sam Adams.
Well yeah.
I mean dark beer is really the only way to go,
but it's got the most kind of gnarly stuff in it too.
Guinness.
Yeah.
God,
I love that stuff.
A lot of bad shit in there though.
And half.
Not good for you.
Oh,
hey,
you guys want some half and half?
So I go get one.
You to get one right now.
Yeah.
All right.
Go get some drugs.
We'll do it.
Fuck it.
Like,
uh,
some,
something with clear booze or something like this on it gets on with clear
Buddhists.
Okay.
Is the bar open?
I don't know what time is five 15?
Maybe the fuck are you doing?
You promising shit you can't deliver if I can get so,
um,
so what about coffee?
Dig Coffee.
Yeah.
And uh,
when you look at the epidemiology,
probably the more you drink,
the better.
Some people or you drink.
Yeah,
I mean it's like three,
four cups a day.
Now the problem is that usually people don't drink espresso or straight coffee.
They usually dumping a bunch of sugar in it.
So that's kind of the,
the caveat with it.
But uh,
it decreases diabetes rates there.
Yo,
you just drank your diabetes away.
Yeah,
yeah.
Really elucidate what,
say that again about diabetes decreases diabetes rate decreases cardiovascular
disease rates.
Like it's good.
It's good stuff.
Wow.
Yeah.
But now let's take that,
let's say you're a police or firefighter and you're working night shift and
you're working out like crazy and you're using caffeine to like drive a
lifestyle that is totally over the top.
Then it's not necessarily good.
It's going to,
it's going to get into some adrenal fatigue.
Your adrenals are the,
you know the hormones.
It released cortisol and it deals with stress and you can completely bombed that
whole system out and then you can drop testosterone levels and drop your immune
function.
When that friend of mine,
he quit coffee for that very reason is adrenal started failing.
Right?
Right.
So you can overdo it in that regard,
but it's kind of like lifestyle plus bad lifestyle plus too much coffee is bad,
but if you have a lifestyle that's a little bit more sedate,
like when we go on vacation,
I can drink coffee all day long and it doesn't phase me when I'm working and
I've got deadlines and stuff and they've got that base level of stress,
then I can't do much coffee.
That's interim steps a day because that's when a lot of people would think that
you would need it.
You're stressed out,
you need do you need some energy,
then you take the coffee.
But yeah,
I,
that's when you could overdo it.
Interesting thing like if you,
uh,
for more cognitive type stuff like writing or trying to do creative work doing
nicotine gum.
Yeah.
I've heard of that.
That's crazy.
It's amazing.
That's one of the things that a Steven King said he missed about smoking.
He said the synaptic responses when he was writing it would be like much
improved with,
with cigarettes.
Yeah.
And the Nikki,
the big,
that's the right way to say it's an haptic response.
Is that what's going on when you writing and making connections and ideas,
creativity and nicotine gum can make you creative.
Yeah.
And,
and like there's good studies showing that a nicotine is preventative against
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's is be good for your heart too,
right?
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
But you've got to remove the delivery system,
which is tobacco well,
which is 590 different chemicals jammed in addition to that stuff.
Yeah,
yeah.
I did a thing once.
Uh,
it's me and my friend Adam Ferrara,
he,
he used to smoke cigarettes.
I don't know if he still does.
He's a comedian and that a TV show,
um,
a top gear.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We did a thing together a long time ago was this play thing and I had to play
this a poet who was like,
like completely full of himself and smoked all day and smoked like a Frenchman
smoke backwards.
And I only smoked like four or five cigarettes while we were rehearsing this day
and I had to quit.
I said,
I can't do this part.
I can't do it,
man.
I feel like I'm gonna throw up.
Right?
Like I can't smoke a cigarette.
Like the whole thing was I'm supposed to be smoking the whole time.
Like,
how the fuck do you guys do this?
Like this is nuts.
Like you're poisoning the shit.
Like I felt like I was becoming a vampire,
like felt that taking over me.
I'm like,
no,
no.
You got to take these back.
What a,
what a madness,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
when you look at tobacco,
like when,
when ever it hit somewhere it spreads fast and it sticks pretty hard.
Well,
the real,
the real man,
this is how many people fucking die from it.
And yet it's still so prevalent.
And even amongst young people in 2012 the Internet out there,
for whatever reason,
there's this weird romantic pull towards self destruction through use of
tobacco.
It's really fucking strange too.
You have a read a Malcolm Gladwell's books was his,
the tipping point.
I think it was the tipping point,
but he,
he talked about the fact that if you tried to demonize something and make it not
cool,
that kids are going to gravitate towards it even course.
Course.
Yeah.
Well,
anything their parents don't want him to do,
get the fuck away
for me.
They just want to like stop telling me what to do.
You Cock sucker.
Right.
Give me that cigarette.
Oh my dad's an asshole.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
But that hopefully can be avoided.
Sorry,
the bar was closed so I couldn't get any clear drinks.
No problem.
But I have vodka on ice if you want that.
Yeah,
I get do.
Otherwise it's only us drinking.
I'm going to drink this Guinness with pride now.
No one.
It's actually good for me.
Sort of.
Kind of,
but not the wheat.
Yeah.
If we could figure out some way to make it without wheat or barley,
it's just,
just shitty for your
Rodney.
What is the best alcohol?
Is there a better alcoholic drink?
Just anything clear like by clear Tequila,
whiskey,
whiskey.
Whiskey is clear.
Yeah.
I mean it just,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
it doesn't have sugar.
It doesn't have gluten.
So holy cat.
Wow.
What does that in there?
That's a whole lot of vodka.
Vodka trying to get them fucked up,
man.
Um,
does marijuana have any adverse effects on performance?
Yeah.
I mean it's going to impact lung function to some degree.
If you really go to town on marijuana,
it's got enough of a phyto estrogenic effect that you can suppress testosterone.
Like that old wives' tale about dudes growing tits because they smoke too much
weed.
Is that like their diet?
It's became dry hits Kenya,
you can't grow tits.
You can,
you can suppress testosterone.
How much do you have to be smoking
and do that smoke a lot.
I mean,
yeah,
you've got to go soon.
Yeah.
But you know,
it pots and other,
it's interesting winning contrasted with say like tobacco,
you don't see the same type of uh,
uh,
emphysema.
You don't see the same type of like carcinogenic effects even though you've got
all,
I mean you're creating a ton of different chemicals.
Um,
when you burn something,
you make these things polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons,
these particles that get in between DNA and can cause problems.
When you look at the research on marijuana and you should just don't see the
same types of things pop popping up now for a,
a hard charging athlete,
I think that you would probably be better off if you want to have a relaxing
evening,
like making some brownies or something like that.
Like the delivery system is going to change the effects a lot for sure.
Well,
the delivery delivery system changes the effects but is also vaporizing,
which is the same sort of delivery system,
very similar delivery system,
but you're just getting like the THC vapor and you're not getting all the other
goodies.
Yeah.
All the Birch Shit,
right.
They say that marijuana smoke is actually an expectorant and it's good for
cleaning out lungs.
Like if you've got some shit and your lungs,
he smoked some weed,
but that could just be pot talk.
Um,
there's some stuff like Mullen also,
which is used for that.
Hey,
I could see that to some degree,
but what is Mullen?
It,
it's uh,
actually a North American herb,
like traditional native American kind of medicine and stuff like that.
We'd have some other benefits,
but yeah,
it's,
uh,
in folklore it's used as an expectorant as well.
Now what about like Advil and Ibuprofen and nonsteroidal antiinflammatories or
those dangerous for your bond?
They're super dangerous.
Real,
Eh,
each year,
thousands of people,
I don't know,
like,
uh,
it'd be easy to do a doctor Google on that,
but to see,
you know,
how many deaths there are each year due to a insights,
nonsteroidal anti inflammatory overdoses.
And there's some really fucked up stuff like,
uh,
with um,
Vicodin.
They pair Vikatin with Acetaminophen Tylenol with the express purpose so that
people don't take more of it to get like a narcotic effect because it will cause
liver damage.
And there are thousands of people that ended up dying,
but you know,
inadvertently because they may have a drink and then they take some Vicodin,
which are not really supposed to do,
but the Acetaminophen makes the whole thing so much more toxic.
Like they're,
they're literally killing people and to know better effect versus taking let you
know,
if somebody has some legitimate pain,
just taking some opiates is going to be really powerful on that.
May Not want to stay on that forever because this stuff's super addictive and
has all kinds of other side effects.
But a lot of our,
our kind of drugs policy,
even on the Orthodox,
you know over the counter side is really goofy and the stuff is,
is dangerous.
Like there are a lot of people who will work out,
get sore,
take ensades to go work out again,
it ends aids,
nonsteroidal inflammatories and it's,
it's bad on a lot of levels.
One of them,
you know,
I mentioned the horn nieces before,
like the adaptation to exercise.
If you take insides in conjunction with exercise,
you're blocking some of the adaptation.
So it's that same thing.
It's kind of like,
you know,
exercising and in missing sleep,
like you're not going to adapt to the exercise the way that you want to have a
backache and you take Ibuprofen,
you're actually fucking yourself.
[inaudible]
you're fucking yourself out of some potential healing.
Yeah.
It,
you know,
but it's tough to say.
Like I,
I tweaked my back a number of years ago.
I used to compete in powerlifting and one time I did something wrong,
my SEI joint got tweaked and like I couldn't stand up.
Like I was totally,
you know,
bent over sideways,
twist it up.
And so taking some Ibuprofen then can relax the muscles a little bit.
It brings the inflammation down,
but use it in acute fashion.
You use it for like,
you know,
a day or two for a specific problem instead of what folks do,
which is basically staying on it continuously so that
those people are fucking themselves.
They're,
yeah.
You're poisoning yourself.
Yeah.
What about for athletes?
Is there a negative effect of it that is shown in camps?
There's problems with not huge increase tendon ruptures because the tendons
don't heal,
decreases cardiac output.
So there's a lot of reasons for not using it and for just,
you know,
like taking some fish oil,
getting your vitamin D levels up by either being out in the sun or supplementing
with vitamin D smart training.
Periodizing your training a little bit,
you know,
stuff like that.
Yeah.
I've never heard that Ibuprofen was so bad.
That's so important.
It's such a important information.
I had always felt like it can't be good,
but I didn't,
I had no idea it was that bad.
It's really,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
it's very powerful for like an acute injury.
So you tweak your back,
your roll an ankle or something and it really suppresses inflammation very
powerfully.
So use it then and use it then only,
yeah.
Yeah.
Use It,
you know,
like one dose to try to knock him.
So when people,
you know,
and people say,
oh,
I have a headache,
give me those things.
They just pop them all the time.
Horrible idea.
Okay.
Yeah.
Very important.
I have a lot of friends who could benefit from that information.
Yeah.
Um,
what should you take when you have inflammation?
Is there any sort of a,
a dietary remedy or is there anything that you could replace Ibuprofen with
that's a good anti inflammatory that's actually beneficial or healthy fish oil
and vitamin D,
just keeping those levels,
those two fish oil really does work for folks who don't know if you've ever had
joint pain and Jujitsu,
a lot of guys get elbow pain.
You're always like fighting off armbars and Camorra's and stuff and your,
your joint can tweak the law.
And that cranks fish oil makes a fucking tremendous difference.
A real difference between me walking around and no pain or me walking around
like,
Eh,
what's that?
You know,
it really feel a difference.
I mean,
it sounds crazy that you're actually like lubing your joints,
but that really is what's going on.
Yeah.
And you get a lot of mileage out of fish oil.
Vitamin D is really,
really important.
And how much official,
I should just take it day two to four grams,
which isn't a ton,
but you know Graham,
so when you have a milligram,
you should take 10 of those were 100 milligrams.
1,000 milligrams has a gram.
Right?
So 10 that's what I take.
I take 10 a day,
10 of the 100 milligrams.
Oh really?
Okay.
So they must be really smart.
Yeah.
So that's gonna be like one gram.
You take two grams.
Yeah.
Wow.
You're an animal.
But
I had cancer,
a thousand milligrams.
I bet they're one brand.
So if they are,
then it's how many for two to four the land planning each,
but for a thousand milligrams.
How many?
One gram.
Oh it is one grand.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well I'm going off dude,
cause I'm,
I'm taking 10 of those.
You travel a lot and stuff.
You're probably,
it's probably good.
Yeah.
Makes a difference man.
When I don't do it,
it sounds ridiculous.
I take five in the morning and five at night,
but when I don't do it,
I feel a difference.
Take it with food though,
right?
Always.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
something that I do that I just incorporate it because someone told me that you
said this,
I don't even know if you really said this,
but I,
I have a Kale shake every morning and I start incorporating some fat into it.
Oh yeah.
To uh,
to absorb the vitamins better.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
I use coconut oil.
Is that good?
That's great.
Yeah,
because I'm still not a fan of shakes usually,
but yeah,
it tastes like dog shit.
But I eat a man,
some bacon and eggs.
Nope.
Big Nights.
It's just as good.
And you like Kale shake?
I do.
I liked the way it makes me feel.
Man.
Aye.
It's one thing when I,
when I blend like a Kale and cucumber and I use a big chunk of 'em,
uh,
ginger and four or five cloves of garlic.
I've been going with five lately and then pineapples,
but the new fruit I used to use pairs and then the coconut oil and I'm telling
you,
man,
it's so rich.
It's feels so ridiculously nutritious.
Like right when I eat it,
my body's like,
whoa.
First of all the garlic and the ginger alone just makes your whole body whoa.
It's like sends a message like,
Holy Shit,
we were delivering some legs.
It's open book.
I tried to make it Joe.
I couldn't do a keynote as good a man when it comes to know terrible,
disgusting Shit.
I ginger and it was just too fiqh and duty your poop though.
Oh my God.
I've never been,
I've never enjoyed pooping more in my life.
It's like it becomes a,
it would be epic.
You would be like a goose yourself at that point comes in an event.
Yeah,
because I eat normally at night,
but that's how I start off every day.
I started doing this because of,
uh,
Kevin James,
Kevin James did this movie called,
uh,
here comes the boom.
We plays an MMA fighter,
comes out in October,
and he lost 80 pounds for this movie.
And the way he lost it was by,
he went on a totally Vegan Diet.
Um,
and he,
the first thing he did every day,
but he had a chef prepare him food all day long while he was in training for
this movie.
So he didn't have to make any choice in it.
It was all in front of them.
This is what you need for dinner.
Here's your snack.
Everything is so food was just falling off them.
But the beginning of every day is a Kale shake.
And he's like,
you got to just choke it down.
The benefits of it that are spectacular.
You don't,
you don't agree with that.
I would go more for like bacon and eggs and a double espresso.
It sounds awesome.
I love this guy is changing every,
I'm going back.
You know
that Waca protein just releases a bunch of dopamine in the brain.
You're happy,
you're centered,
you're focus.
The,
the,
uh,
the caffeine releases dopamine.
So like Bacon and coffee,
when you feel alone,
eggs and coffee is good.
When you feel love,
like you look,
tell you,
Joe,
I've been doing a little bit longer.
Look into your wife's size and you feel loved.
You're feeling dopamine.
And so like Bacon and coffee release dopamine,
so bacon and coffee or love.
So that's incredible.
Bacon and coffee are love.
It totally makes sense why they're so delicious.
Like there's an emotional connection to them as with chocolate.
Right,
right,
right.
There's an emotional connection to the foods as well.
Bacon and coffee or lunch it,
try one month of Bacon,
eggs and coffee and then try one month of Kale shake and let me know.
But doesn't the Kale shake or isn't like the nutrients?
Like really important?
Like the,
the,
the nutrients you get from cal shakes.
I mean they make me feel great.
I fucking love it.
I mean,
I'm going to keep eating it for the pooky alone.
Give it a whirl.
Give,
give it a chip.
It,
try it out for one month.
But I mean,
you don't need all those vitamins.
And the Kale,
you don't need all those vitamins and the salary and the cucumber and the
garlic.
All Great.
But I mean,
you could,
you could get that with a salad later and,
and you know,
it's like if you got some good,
yeah,
really?
Yeah.
So it's sort of some salad,
olive oil,
giant bundle of vegetables ground down to like a liquid,
right?
I'm not like benefiting myself and having all those extra nutrients you are,
but it's so the fact that you put coconut oil in there as good because a lot of
people make all that stuff low fat and a lot of the fido chemicals,
a lot of the antioxidants only dissolve in fat.
So when you put that,
it's kind of like doing an exome,
but just a regular salad is not good enough.
You have to have some like a good like ranch dressing or something or olive oil
or something.
Yeah.
You'd have to blue cheese dressing out with wings
that absorbs more nutrients out of the wings.
Um,
so you really do need some fat with you in your dressing if you want to absorb
all the nutrients of your salad.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Because people will say,
I want the low fat,
low fat and low fat that they're not getting nutrition.
All the nutrients are just shooshing in and out.
And like before I had to take a leak,
you asked me about like minerals and stuff like that.
It's uh,
a bunch of the things that you would normally be able to get out of food is it,
you know,
it's enhanced the way you absorb it if you have some fat with it,
that's amazing.
So when people just eat a regular salad,
just straight lettuce and greens,
you're really fucking yourself.
You really should have something,
you should have something with it.
Either eats chicken,
something,
something fatty,
she needs something fat.
So if you're Vegan,
then you would throw some almond butter in it.
You'd have some coconut oil in it or something like that.
And if you just eat vitamins on their own,
it's useless.
Like just raw vitamins on an empty stomach doesn't really work.
You don't absorb them as well and like what percentage you think you would
absorb?
Gosh,
is there still turns fluorescent so I mean you're still absorbing it with that
regard,
but the vitamins definitely works synergistically with a lot of the products and
food.
So I think it's Saturday is taken so you'll get some sort of an effect.
Have you taken on an empty stomach but a very mineralized yeah,
and you know much less effect stomach upset.
Yeah,
it'd be one that's a big known.
Yeah.
I will not hard pills.
Especially like compact and multivitamins or something like that.
A little weird.
Yeah.
You might be facing a,
wouldn't Knutsen salad be better than say ranch dressing full on rat ranch
dressing?
You know nursing is delicious specially with Beijing.
Yeah.
Well this mother fucker is trying to lose weight though.
He doesn't want that ranch dressing
that's high in fat.
Raw nuts especially,
right?
Yeah,
because you tend not to overeat them.
It's that palatability thing again.
So if you roast them and salt them,
they taste better and you can eat right.
You go off.
Yeah,
that's true.
I don't eat raw almonds nearly.
It's like as much as those loves ones,
when they're smokey Joe,
smokey,
Ahmond's,
whatever.
I don't know what that smokey shit is.
It's,
it's yum.
Smokey y'all good for you man.
So there's no need for cal shakes.
Is this what you're telling me?
Cause I've been,
I've been living off this.
It's you like it definitely go for it.
But you know,
I,
I think some of the mixed green,
um,
you know,
foods can be kind of cool,
but it said,
dude just walked in.
Why don't you lock the door son?
Shit's ridiculous.
Somebody just walked in.
We have a non-secure studio.
Oops.
Normally,
always secure.
Um,
so,
so you don't need all those nutrients.
And how much vegetable nutrients do you need in a day if you are,
if you're going to eat like bacon and eggs for breakfast,
now here's the deal,
like bacon and eggs for breakfast because people usually wine about,
you know,
I don't have time.
I,
you know,
I need to get stuff done quickly.
So I,
I call it like the meat and nuts breakfast where it's basically like some eggs
and bacon.
So you know like some Turkey with some almonds or something like that.
So it's quick,
it's easy.
You get a dose of dopamine,
you get,
you know,
your hormones kind of balance going right out of the gate.
If someone is a hard charging athlete,
they're probably going to need throw some carbs in it.
I'm just saying like general.
So if you're going to work out later in the day,
you might want to start with like some fruit or like some yams or sweet potatoes
or or something like that with this.
But that first meal,
if you make it mainly protein and fat,
you have good rock,
solid energy level.
Um,
I usually train it noon.
Like if I'm able to get into Jira to at noon,
then I eat it either one or two.
And so I'll eat lunch then.
So I usually do like that.
So what do you do for breakfast?
Breakfast is usually bacon and eggs over when you go train a couple hours later,
four hours later I train with carbs.
And they can and post workout.
I eat like a giant sweet potato,
like mega sweet potato with some protein and I've got some veggies.
And then my dinner is a little bit of protein with like a metric ton of veggies
and then some fat.
So like I'm doing like a boatload of like cooked veggies or like a salad or
something.
So I'm getting all the veggies kind of at the end of the day with a bunch of
fat.
I'm streamlining my,
my breakfast,
but I'm getting enough protein in the morning so that my energy level is good,
my blood sugar is good and all that stuff.
And then I'm recovering from training by doing some post workout carbs and say
like if I'm doing,
when I start doing jets,
cause I'm old now and just beat down and everything,
I'm not really doing much else.
I might lift weights a little bit or do a little gymnastics,
but I'm not really needing a lot of glycogen repletion between workouts.
But if he had somebody that was doing multiple sessions a day,
then you just start doing more carb repletion feet.
So you know,
breakfast would be protein and yams and sweet potatoes and fruit.
So you throw down the carbs based on what your kind of,
what glycogen you're burning and your
workouts.
I've never heard anybody advocate bacon and eggs for breakfast with with coffee.
Sounds like a heaven.
It seems too good to be true man.
What about potato?
So there are the good,
bad,
great post workout,
post workout because you're the carbon sugar.
Yeah but but not good just as a meal.
Not Good.
Like you eating dinner with steak and potatoes,
the potatoes not right.
What is it?
What is wrong with potato as opposed to like sweet potato,
you know,
any hyber less nutrients.
But you know
again it's a little bit specific to the person.
Somebody like you that's lean and athletic and doing a lot of activity.
Then for dinner,
a piece of meat with a baked potato or a sweet potato,
that's fine because you,
you've got the activity level where you need that,
that level of carbon.
Take somebody that's trying to lose some weight and they,
maybe I have some insulin dysregulation,
like their blood sugars go high and low.
Their insulin goes high and low.
They would probably be better off not having that.
So it's a folks want to paint like a kind of a one size fits all picture,
but it's very specific.
You know,
it's like,
are we talking about a metabolically broken type two diabetic?
Are we talking about an athlete?
Are we talking about just kind of,
uh,
recreationally active stay at home mom?
You know,
so it's really important to consider who we talking about.
What are their goals,
what are they working towards?
And that will steer the boat both with regards to their training and also their
nutrition.
Yeah.
I've also,
I've always felt that with,
with athletics that there's a reason why when you have a heavy weightlifting
workout,
you crave meat.
I mean,
it's,
it's a very distinct craving.
If you are a meat eater,
if you're,
the type of person eats meat when you work out right away,
like right when it's over,
you want to fucking steak,
I want a burger.
You want some,
your body's saying give me some meat bitch.
Right,
right.
It's probably an instinct that,
I mean your,
your,
your muscles in your body are probably sending a message,
right?
Yeah.
It's a great way to stabilize your blood sugar,
eat some protein.
And that is going to be a slow release glucose into your system because your
body can convert the amino acids into glucose.
Like kind of the ideal thing is like a pretty good whack of protein with a
little bit of carbs.
Should you just keep things nights.
Did you not drink water while you eat?
It's not a bad idea and it's a little bit lunatic fringe but uh,
you dilute the digestive a little bit and I think that you probably have better
digestion without,
you know,
liquids during the meal.
So like in part of it too,
you notice when people drink liquid with their meal,
they just kind of gum there food once or twice and then they take some water and
like shoot it down and the eyes bulge because it's like a python swallowing like
a swamp rat or something is true.
People chew less.
We're so lazy,
we'd rather drink water with it to shut down.
Yeah.
People are so fucking stupid.
So it's better to not have water with it and to chew your food up really well.
Totally.
When you wake up.
No.
A Mike Dolce says you wake up and she'd have like eight ounces of water before
you do anything.
Just look at smart.
Yeah.
I mean more and more than that.
And I'm what to do during a day.
You know,
when I get up I usually do almost a quarter of water.
I actually,
yeah,
I do maybe half of it,
you know,
in a pretty good shot.
Uh,
yeah cause it,
it,
that stimulates the digestive stuff.
So I'll do that.
I'll get hot.
Not Super Hot.
I mean it just,
just one.
So it's not like,
you know,
frozen cold because I'm getting it out of the filter out of the fridge.
I'll pop it in the microwave and heat it up just a little bit,
you know,
so it's like room temperature or something.
So I'll do half of that.
Like immediately I'll go sit down on the computers,
start checking email.
I've got a stove top espresso maker where I've got coffee that starts brewing.
I've got a timer for that.
That's six minutes.
Usually I finish the water within like six to 10 minutes.
And then I throw my bacon on my grill,
which I grill it really low temperature long time,
like 200 degrees.
Slow,
slow grilled Navajo Grill Bacon.
Yeah.
Why do you do that?
Amazing.
It is amazing.
He Bacon everyday.
Not Everyday but I mean a lot of days but you know,
all go through a terror where I have bacon a lot and then I won't have it for
two months,
three months.
Like I'll,
I'll just be like,
oh,
I'm over it and I'm done.
Yeah.
So just slow grilling over Ligo,
irregular grill liquid.
It's electric grill,
you know,
like nonstick deal and,
and uh,
I just put it on 200 and it's slow grills for like two hours and it just makes
it so amazing to our bacon.
Yeah,
that's like a fetish type.
Sounds like heaven.
The how?
It's like burning incense.
It's
on my mind in so many ways on this show.
I just had blood work done for life insurance.
I'm 40 years old,
New York life did like the full deal,
like crawled up my who hot,
you know,
all the blood work and everything and I be,
I have the blood work parameters,
the bio parameters of somebody who's 28 years old.
So like,
and they gave me a perfect,
you know,
health score,
they,
they've never had a 40 year old male with as good a biomarkers is.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
And I was talking to their underwriter about the whole Paleo thing and I'm like,
yeah,
because the,
the one thing they dinged me on,
I'm five,
975 pounds.
And so according to their charts,
I was overweight and I was like,
well,
I'd lift weights and I'm reasonably lane and I shot him pictures and everything
and the guy's like,
okay,
that's cool.
That's hilarious that,
that,
that's such a stupid way of out if someone's at the way.
Yeah.
So stupid.
It's like,
it's just saying,
Nah,
there's no variables.
Right.
It's right.
It's ridiculous.
And it being 180 pounds and five nine is equal.
Whether you lift weights or where you are overweight.
I'm eat Twinkies.
It's so,
it's such a silly thing.
People look at that and like you need to go and get your body fat tested.
You need to get your,
your body mass indicator needs to be done.
[inaudible] soaking or the electrical when we stand on it,
what's the best one to fit the,
the uh,
the immersion tank is really the only way to go.
That's the best way to go.
Yeah.
Their stuff is so highly variable.
And most of it is geared towards overweight people.
So if you have an athletic population using it,
it's not even on the same planet.
It's not even close.
Yeah.
I've heard that.
The um,
the one that tests you,
you stand on it and if it gets your body fat,
if you're dehydrated,
it registers that as more fat because it's more resistance for the electricity
pass through your system.
Fascinated.
I probably run like eight,
eight to 10% body fat,
reasonably lean,
not like,
not like ridiculously lean but reasonably lane.
And there was some sort of a health fair going on and I jumped on one of these
scales and it put me at 32% body fat.
Whoa.
And you,
you could imagine that maybe it's like,
okay,
maybe it's 12 or maybe even 15 which would be almost 50% off,
but it was like,
okay,
yeah,
there's something serious like broken.
What is your normal body fat?
I think like seven to seven to ten eight to 10 something like that.
I like to stay at that reasonably lane.
Yeah.
If you get leaner than that,
then I noticed my performance tanks.
So like you would like to be like kind of Brag,
Pitt,
fight club lean,
but then like you can't actually fight.
You can't,
that's not funny.
Well dudes that are really super lean,
when you see them competing in MMA that have cut an incredible amount of weight
and how much of an impact does that have?
Just the fact that even when they rehydrate,
they have to fight so lean.
I don't know it.
You know that on the individual,
some people run lean and still have some good performance,
but you know it wired into our brain,
wired into our genetics is a really tightly controlled mechanism to know how
much body fat we have and the,
usually we want some not too much because you start getting unhealthy with too
much,
but if you start getting really,
really lean,
your body registers that as a stress because you don't have much survival
reserve.
Like if there was a starvation scenario,
then you know your body starts getting anxious about that in a little vague
cortisol,
it will suppress your,
your work output because it doesn't want you to be two lane.
You're making people so happy today.
Do understand what you're doing here.
You're saying bacon and eggs in the morning is good.
You're saying coffee is good.
Look what I just bought off with facing.
You need some fat in it.
You say it a couple of drinks or tactical Cancun.
It lasts for 10 years.
It has 18 servings that can't be good,
Brian,
whatever.
And then you get a real bacon.
Samuel,
listen to what he said about preservatives.
Real bad.
Some shit of you're dying.
You're in a fucking bunker now.
If you're camping and you need to use their base,
you run out of the bay camping,
not tactical.
There's a fucking AK 47 on the trunk,
shows you what that is.
That box is designed for when the end of the world comes,
you need bacon.
The doomsday bunker don't eat the shit that's only going to be here at the end
of the world.
Okay.
I would say get some real bacon.
He's silly pitch.
So what I need to do is start my own farm and cook my own Bacon.
Slow for two hours.
That's yeah,
that's started.
Yeah,
dude,
that's the route to like a happy life.
How do you start when you started the bacon?
I get up,
we have a three month old kid now,
daughter,
and so I take the early morning shifts,
so I grab her from my wife about five 30 or six play with her,
get the bacon going,
do all that stuff.
So I'm,
I'm up.
Then.
Yeah,
it's a fetish thing to our bake.
It's a bit fetish.
You know,
I'm,
I'm cooking it ahead of time cause my wife gets up around eight and so I'm
cooking it.
And then about the time she starts getting up,
then it gets,
makes going.
My coffee's already been done.
I make her some coffee and then we get the whole,
how did you know that this is a good move to have it slow cook for two hours.
So my buddy Matt [inaudible] who's a Harvard phd chemist and just,
we call them the cracking.
It's like unleashed the cracking,
you know?
And he's,
he's just wickedly smart dude.
But he did all this research and he's like slow cooking meat is the only way
that you should do it.
You're a moron if you do anything else.
Really.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Cause I cook steaks quick.
Yeah,
it's so good.
They're super good.
And I mean the grilling deal is,
you know,
there's a big argument for senior,
how do you get like that outer crispy Brown?
You don't,
but you think about someone like the pit barbecue and stuff,
which is a slow cooked.
It's amazing.
So,
so I mean there,
there's,
there's some tradeoffs
that too,
but I also liked the medium rare steak is done correctly.
I guess the Argentinian method of cooking steaks is a low and slow cooking
method,
right?
Yeah.
They have their,
they have a love of steak as well.
Right.
And really good meat.
Grass Fed.
Yeah.
Well that's how most of the fucking world is.
I love that.
Brazil just want a big lawsuit over Monsanto.
Do you know this?
No,
I didn't hear about this.
I know that Monsanto was trying to push into a
Mexico.
Yeah.
They,
I'm sure they're going to push everywhere eventually.
But the Brazil,
once a multibillion dollar lawsuit,
a bunch of farmers from Brazil won against Monsanto.
It's just we got to figure out a way to let people grow grass and have the
animals eat grass.
Cause that's the healthiest way.
I mean it really,
it's people.
It should be,
someone should be able to say,
hey listen,
this is,
you guys are,
we're being silly here.
Let's do this the way these animals are supposed to be eating.
Like,
we're,
we,
we see what happens when we make them eat animals,
right?
We're making them eat themselves,
which is the most insane thing about farming ever,
right?
You know,
the mad cow disease,
ladies and gentlemen,
you don't know it was started because they made cows eat other fucking cows.
They just had another,
uh,
equal,
I break out in the way that this equal light is,
it becomes problematic when you feed cattle grains.
It increases stomach acid content in the cattle.
It gives some gerd,
gastroesophageal reflux disease type type deal because of the yellow elevated
acid in this,
uh,
e coli that is normally killed by stomach acid.
You selectively breed it to survive high acid environment.
So the stuff that normally our own stomach acid would kill because we feed the
cattle grains instead of grass.
We actually produce like a superbug that then if it gets some other genetic
modifications,
it makes it deadly and it can survive going through the digestive process where
normally we would kill it so that,
you know,
the,
the grain feeding of cattle is just like,
it's super expensive.
It's dirty.
It's,
it's a,
yeah.
Yeah.
But there is a benefit of packing on more fat on the animal,
which makes it a little bit more juicy when you cook it.
Yeah,
I mean,
but you know,
it's,
it's interesting though,
like if you,
you find folks like what we'd spent a bunch of time in,
in Nicaragua and stuff and the folks from there,
you get used to eating the meat that's grass fed and it's definitely leaner,
but it's very,
very flavorful and it's different.
I think that more than Amy almost,
it's almost a little more gaining.
Yeah.
By my mortgage people have that association.
Gaming like gave me like,
he I think like vibrant.
Right.
That's what I,
when I,
when I say gaming,
I mean like funky grass fed meat tastes more like butter.
Yeah.
You know,
it's got kind of like a buttery consistency to it.
Grass fed beef is really delicious.
Yeah.
Grain Fed beef is a little bit more,
well,
there's sick.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
You're eating a sick animal.
That's why I don't like King Coburn.
Yeah.
Scary stuff.
The one in Food Inc when they had the hole in the animal side because it was
like
fucking stomach acids were rotting.
Yeah,
it's a race against,
when you feed cattle grains,
it's a race against time to get them fast enough to take them to market before
they die from all the gastrointestinal problems.
And here's a,
here's an interesting thing.
There's a guy,
a Dr. Michael leads who's kind of a,
a long time,
a low carb guy,
but he's kind of a Paleo guy to really interesting tude but he was doing some
research on um,
just like diets and different things.
And he went to,
he's from Arkansas,
so he went to a feed lot of feed store and he asked the guy,
hey,
what do you,
what do you feed animals to get them fat?
You know,
like horses and cattle and pigs and all that.
And I'm like,
well,
the guy upstairs has this manual and it was like feeding manual for weight gain
and animals or something.
And he opens it up.
And when you looked at the ratios of protein,
carbohydrate to fat,
it was like identical to the food pyramid.
I mean fucking spot on.
Whereas used to we we,
you know,
like the four food groups even,
which like when you and I were kids was still more the,
the Gig.
Um,
you typically ate more fat,
more protein and less carbs just in general.
So it was really interesting like the formula,
the standardized formula in this huge tome of a book too to get animals fat for,
for sale was identical to like the,
the food ratio is recommended by the Ada.
Wow.
It's a fattening diet because of the carbohydrate content,
because of the allowance for,
for refined sugars and stuff like that.
And you said this all started being implemented in the 1970s the recommendation
for grains?
Yeah.
You know,
prior to like the late sixties,
early seventies,
whenever you went to a doctor and you were overweight,
you were recommended,
you were prescribed a low carb diet for like a hundred years.
That was the norm.
And it,
this is a Gary Tobbs wrote a really interesting book,
good calories,
bad calories to huge.
Like you can only read it like a page at a time.
It's like reading biblical text.
It's super thick,
but for a hundred years it was just understood that if you were overweight you
cut out like beer,
potatoes,
pasta,
rice.
I eat protein and fat and green vegetables and you lost weight.
And it was,
it was just woven into,
you know,
all of medicine.
And then around the 1950s we had this idea that uh,
heart heart disease was caused by fat consumption,
which had never been born out by the,
the science.
It was interestingly a vegetarian on a political committee that kind of put this
thing forward and ended up in acting a bunch of the laws that push this stuff
forward.
And we've spent billions of dollars trying to prove that saturated fat causes
cardiovascular disease.
They had the Framingham heart study,
which was 30,000 nurses or something like that,
tracked over like 30 years.
And the nurses that ate the most fat,
the most saturated fat,
eight the most calories were the leanest,
had the highest energy levels and tended to be the longest lived.
And so every,
I mean it's totally the emperor's new clothes type thing,
like everything we've been told it's just fucking wrong.
Like,
and not petite mall.
The wrong like grand wrong.
It's horrible.
What about salt causing problems?
A lot of things in biology have what's called a u shaped curve.
So like if you have too low of intake,
you have a high rate of disease.
As the intake increases,
disease drops to a low point and then above a certain point disease starts going
up and there's so many nutrients and biological processes.
Exercise is a good one.
You don't have any exercise.
You're likely to die from a host of problems.
You have a good amount of exercise.
Your likelihood of being healthy and dying decreases to much exercise in your
life to die.
The dies during an ultra marathon.
So salt is exactly the same.
Like we should have some salt and it's actually,
it's like three to five grams a day.
It's a reasonably high level that hits that,
that really low edge of of a decreasing.
Yeah,
of being beneficial.
There are some people that respond very negatively to chloride,
which salt is sodium chloride and they respond very negatively to it.
They retain water at Jacks up their blood pressure there.
So there are some people that they need to be pretty low salt,
otherwise they're going to have cardiovascular problems.
So it does it cause hypertension and people if they overdose in it or is that a
misnomer?
It,
it can but it interestingly,
when you consume carbohydrates and your insulin levels go up,
when insulin goes up,
another hormone called aldosterone goes up and aldosterone causes
your body to retain salt.
And when you retain salt you retain water.
So it's actually an indirect way that sodium elevates blood pressure.
But if your insulin levels are high,
say you're eating a high carb diet,
you know like grain based,
you know Ada recommended diet and you cut your salt back,
you may still have very high blood pressure because of insulin problem,
not necessarily the salt problem.
Where's you're eating a little lower carb,
you can eat some salt and it's not going to be problematic at all.
So most people don't have sodium issues.
I would say it's less an issue of sodium and more an issue of carbohydrate and
also sleep.
Circling back around like sleep is only one or two nights of Miss Sleep.
Like poor sleep can make you as insulin resistant as a type two diabetic.
So I mean it,
it's a no joke deal at to ranges,
insulin function like immediately.
Have you ever fucked around with an isolation tank?
You know,
I haven't,
I have not.
I've done it.
I've done a bunch of uh,
meditation,
all kinds of psychedelics.
I,
I've done all kinds of other stuff while you're into recovery so much.
Yeah,
I have,
I've never had the opportunity to mess with it.
I've got to get you involved with it somehow or another and,
and see what your results are because I know you're so conscious of your,
your rest and one of the most relaxing feelings ever is like doing like a couple
hours in a tank,
right?
The high céline deal.
And you just drift off.
Yes.
800 pounds of Epson salts in there,
right?
93 and a half degree temperature.
Same as your skin.
You float into it.
I mean you,
you feel nothing after the first 20 minutes.
Once you get over the fact that your long and water,
you've flying through space,
you're completely weightless and everything's sort of lengthens out.
It feels,
it's so relaxing,
right?
So if you'll hear things go pop like your,
like your muscles will like stretch out on why?
Because it's literally a feeling of complete weightlessness.
You're floating in the water.
Right?
It's amazing feeling.
Somebody told me about it but I've just never had a chance.
That's incredible.
I am still to this day amazed at how little coverage and how little exposure the
isolation tank has.
It to me is one of the most amazing tools for first of all,
just for thinking.
Cause it's like meditation is one thing.
I think we,
you know,
we've covered visualization and meditation.
Super important for anybody trying to achieve something,
but there is no alone.
Like that tank,
that tangle loan is you alone from your body.
Right.
I mean you,
you dissipate your,
it's your mind literally untethered from your physical form.
It's just thanking you,
don't see anything.
You don't hear anything.
You don't feel anything.
You just can stay put and not move.
You won't feel the fucking water.
You won't feel your body at all.
You feel like you're flying through the darkness and you're completely alone
with your thoughts,
but it's not disassociative because you don't lose your yourself.
Exactly.
Yourself as,
as introspective as you ever get.
You can't escape your insecurities.
You can't escape your,
your,
your troubles.
You can't escape the things he and you not liking about your do your laziness,
your lack of discipline.
You,
you know,
you can't escape any of it.
It's,
it's you untethered from any distractions,
physical distractions,
and he's spatial,
recognizing colors,
hearing sounds,
all that's gone,
this dark blackness,
no sound,
no nothing.
So amazing environment and it's great for relaxation.
Man.
When I come out of there,
I feel recharged.
I can do two hours in the tank and I felt like I just got up for an from an
awesome like eight hour arresting sleep.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Do do people come and stitch sometimes,
like they get a little little weirded out.
We get weirded out and quit and then you just get out of the tank that can't
handle the aloneness,
the solitude,
the silence.
They can't handle the,
the,
what happens to the mind because in the absence of any sort of sensory input,
the mind can develop a psychedelic state.
Right.
And so you can start hallucinating and having,
you know,
some really,
really crazy and uh,
the almost like lucid dream type situations.
Some people don't like that.
Some people love it and some people,
that's what they're looking forward to.
But just the introspective nature of it and the,
the,
the relaxation that you can achieve inside of there.
I'll be really curious to see what,
how that you would be affected by that.
I can't believe you haven't tried it.
I would love to try it.
You're going to fucking love it.
I'm going to hook.
How long are you in town for?
A Sunday until Sunday.
If I'm,
I set you up at the float lab in Venice.
Can you make a trip down there?
Could you do that?
Uh,
tomorrow I potentially do it.
Okay.
I'll call crash personally and set it up.
It makes the best tanks in the country,
in the world.
Really.
His tanks are there.
They're incredible.
They're,
they look like meat lockers.
They're these giant things and they're really wide and deep and he uses like the
best possible,
uh,
cleaning equipment.
It's all,
all the water's pass through.
Ozone was like,
no,
no worries.
Ever have anything like being in the water and nothing negative.
And he always has a temperature perfect.
And he just,
he's a master at this shit.
This guy is the best in the world and he's in Venice and he will totally hook
it.
I was the flow lab and if enemies interested to go to the float lab.com you
could see the photos of it.
They look like crazy fucking time portals,
these things.
And they really are.
I mean it would,
it really is.
It's like,
if you could take a pill that would put you in that state where you're,
you're in this crazy darkness flying through space,
relieved from all the input from your body,
that would be a crazy fucking drug.
You know,
you're achieving a very strange state without a crazy drug.
Not really wanting to do it,
man.
We got to hook it up.
Oh,
I'm there.
We'll set up.
We'll set it up for sure.
Um,
if people want to follow you,
uh,
the book is called the Paleo Solution.
It is available,
I'm sure.
I'm Amazon except audible.com soon.
You sons of bitches on the beach and you're working on a deal.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
we're,
we're uh,
just finished getting ready to basically bring a mobile recording deal to my
house and then I'll sit down and like bang the thing out and then we'll be good.
So yeah,
if you go to doug.com Brian makes money,
so he's got one of those weird deals with Amazon,
so go there and support.
So the Paleo Solution Diet.
Um,
if anybody else,
if they want to get any more information about this,
what's best way to grow
on it.com.
Everything that anybody would ever need to do this for free on the website.
So like whether you want to lose weight,
if you've got an auto immune disease,
if you're a high level athlete,
you don't have to buy the book,
go to the website,
everything's laid out there for free.
Do it.
And then typically when people do it,
they get great results and then they end up buying the book.
So yeah.
And then I've got a podcast to Paleo solution that's once a week Paleo solution
that's available on iTunes.
Itunes,
yeah.
We're typically between number one and number four in the health category.
Like Oh,
beautiful.
We'll Duke it out with a Jillian Michaels.
I'm doing pretty good on.
Good.
I heard some crazy like someone stole Julian Michael's car and crashed into a
tree.
They broke into her house,
stole her badly.
She would probably kick their ass if she got a whole look.
I think so she's had sex.
How did you like that?
I think she's gay dude.
Yeah.
I don't think,
yeah,
we think she's gay for real though.
She's so hot.
It makes me,
it was hard to believe it's,
you just need some good Dick.
She just needs you Brian,
to be consensus.
Joe,
did you see in persuading?
I've met a lot of guys.
I don't understand.
I mean,
I don't understand how any girl doesn't go gay.
I think they should all go keg.
Most guys are fucking losers,
but I think a lot of these poor girls are not really gay.
They just need some good Dick.
Yup,
sure.
Did you see the pictures?
I put it on.
I don't mean this folks.
Okay.
If you're some crazy fucking like really super leftist person,
you want to label me sexist?
I'm just talking shit.
Okay.
It's fun.
It's just talking shit.
I don't really think you can fuck someone straight.
Okay.
You feel better now.
Take all the joy out of comedy.
Don't you love the exculpatory clause you need on everything.
It's still like,
okay,
this is a plastic bag.
Don't put it over your head.
I keep talking to my other,
I'm sorry Brian,
we'll get right back to you.
But I keep talking about teen people.
You know,
let's say all sharks can suck my dick.
We should kill them all.
She's killing anything that kills you.
I don't really mean that you fucking dummies.
I don't really think you should go out and kill all the sharks,
but that is the reason why I don't surf.
It's cause I don't want to get eaten by a fucking shark.
I know they're out there,
but I don't really think you should kill them all.
You fucking idiots.
I'm going t people fuck the sharks.
They can suck my dick.
You really think a shark can suck my dick and he really thinks that's what I'm
saying.
Some people lack the irony gene that just they don't have a signal for irony.
Well,
not only that,
some people have diarrhea of the mouth and they can't help just saying any
stupid thing that comes into their mind.
And so they put it on Twitter pretty much be us without it.
We just did a three hour podcasts.
I'm talking about mouth,
diarrhea.
I told people that I got a sex change on Twitter the other day and they posted a
photo of my sister because she can look kind of like me
and people really thought I,
I was like dressed in drag or something like that.
That is awesome.
There's a lot of fucking morons out there,
man.
Do you think the dad is an environmental thing?
I mean it's,
it's definitely a way of your extra area of expertise.
We've created them.
An environment
in which a complete moron can not only survive but thrive and they don't have to
be able to get along with other people,
be productive in their own life.
Um,
there's some safety net that will allow them to reproduce it.
I mean,
a idiocracy like the first 10 minutes of the accuracy is it,
we fixed this,
you know,
at some point the sun's going to expand out to the orbit of Mars and it's not
going to matter.
So is that really what it is?
We just let this fucking thing fall apart is fucking write it out.
I mean it,
I don't know,
man.
It's,
it seems like we're here though.
Okay.
If you're 40,
I'm 44,
we're here for a certain amount of years.
We only have a certain amount of time.
Um,
there's gotta be a way to make this a more pleasurable and sustainable
experience for all the people involved in it and all the future generations
before the Sun Burns out.
Yeah,
it's gotta be a way to make it more comfortable.
I just lean towards this whole market based libertarian kind of self
determination and freedom and you know like we have all this fucked up stuff
where we have people that want to marry each other and we won't let him marry
each other and we don't chick filet exactly fill out
cotton chick filet in Boston.
They were going off another,
another part of the country is saying they don't want Chick-Filet.
It's hilarious.
So we get to keep,
the only thing,
it was all spun up over stuff like that.
We dumped a bunch of money into a prohibition,
you know,
tactic on,
on the drug scene that we know just doesn't fucking work.
All it does is eat up resources.
It creates a black market.
Well.
It also
creates jobs though.
The real,
the real problem with keeping drugs illegal is that there's a whole bunch of
people that make their living busing.
People were on drugs.
There's a reason why,
by the way,
these fucking DEA agents keep rating medical marijuana dispensaries.
You don't hear a damn peep about them.
Busting heroin dealers are busting oxycontin factories or busting illegal shit
like meth labs.
They're not doing that.
You don't hear that.
It's very rare because that's dangerous as shit,
you know,
and they know they can go into these pot factories or these pot dispensary or
like a cow.
They're easy to get any scholar.
It's an easy collar and it's,
it's disgusting because there's a business involved in giving these people jobs.
These people that are DEA agents,
they have to fucking do work.
Okay,
so they're taking the easiest road possible to do that work.
They're going after some shit that's illegal.
That doesn't hurt anybody.
I mean it's,
it's one of the worst abuses of the law that we have clinically or,
or rather a classically on record.
Like this is like one of the war.
The worst,
most obvious abuses of the law.
How are you serving or protecting by closing a dispensary,
right?
You're not,
you know you're not,
and yet,
you know,
there,
there's like real problems out there.
You know there's meth labs.
How do these people are on meth?
You go to fucking drive to Riverside drive,
drive around,
drive around to these areas that have meth issues,
where methods in their community.
Where's that math coming from?
It's coming from somewhere.
You fuck.
You need to go find that Matthew assholes.
If you want to find something that's bad,
find something that actually does damage.
They're taking the cheap and easy way out.
Like shitty government employees.
That's the real problem with drugs being illegal is that it gives idiots a job
and keeping things
well and you know,
we're expanding the idiots.
You know,
you have this kind of wacky healthcare thing that you know they want.
And if not the foot soldiers,
it's whoever the fuck tells them they have to go and bust.
It made me maybe the soldiers or the,
the actual officers,
the ones who tried to make a difference.
I mean,
who knows?
Who's the dummy that's telling them they need to close down the medical
marijuana dispensaries.
But that is the only way you can keep all those people employed.
They have to be busting somebody's,
you know,
you,
if you have a million DEA agents or whatever the fuck it is,
and you all of a sudden make marijuana legal,
what the fuck do they do?
You know,
what are the prisons do when they have all these people that are in jail for
something retroactively should be released.
I mean it just because it's a,
they,
they violated a ridiculous law 10 years ago.
They shouldn't be still locked in a fucking cage.
And we've determined that lot is make any sense.
So then what happens?
We let everybody out of the prisons,
the prisons don't make money anymore that the privatized prison stocks go down.
The what are the,
you've got to fire some of the jail guys of the world than they are.
They're going to go crazy with their union.
Yeah.
Industries come and go all the time.
And that's probably one that could stand going.
Yeah,
it could,
but it's not,
it doesn't seem like that's happening in our life.
We need to figure out a way to force feed that like a fog walk doc and just
listen cock suckers.
This is the future.
It's not right to lock people up for marijuana.
You know,
it's,
it's interesting the,
there was a Ron Paul rally and in Nevada that it went to in Reno and it was
huge.
And uh,
uh,
it was all young people and it was like black people and white people and Asian
people.
And I mean Nevada doesn't have that much racial diversity.
And so the fact that there,
there was,
you know,
this mix there and that they were young,
if they were passionate about this kind of libertarian idea,
it was pretty interesting in this Paleo scene.
It's a really interesting overlap with like almost everybody in this Paleocene
as like kind of libertarian politics.
Like they want gay marriage,
they want free drugs.
They,
why is that?
I think it's because they're fucking smart,
you know?
It's like they've kind of,
they've rattled all this stuff around,
you know,
like the,
the,
the vegetarians and I know people are going to hate me but you know,
there's a sense about what we're going to nice our way into a stable world.
But the reality is that the way that nature works is that you have carnivores
and de you know,
herbivores and like there's a biodynamic kind of system there and I think that
people in the Paleo scene more embraced that and they embrace decentralized
farming and pull permit culture and things like that.
But there's a really powerful kind of libertarian element to this Paleo scene
and it's,
it's grown like crazy,
like every 12 months on Google.
It's doubling and,
and as it stands right now,
like it is just growing exponentially.
And so you,
you've got kind of a food oriented kind of exercise oriented scene,
which is a little culty but you know,
it's also got this interesting kind of market based libertarian kind of politics
that that seemed to be woven through.
When you say culty though,
I think it speaks to people's ideas.
It's like,
you know when,
when it comes along,
when something comes along that speaks to what people had sort of surmised on
their own or what,
they didn't have a level four,
it didn't have a direction to put all the facts in and you know,
it's especially when it comes to libertarian ideology and just leaving people
alone,
let them do what the fuck they want to do for so many people.
That's just a big yes.
Like finally like what the fuck is going on?
Is it just this weird ass fucking society?
We're dumb.
People are allowed to thrive and that promotes these ridiculous solutions like a
10,000 year old earth and you know,
supporting ridiculous old texts that were written back when people thought the
world was flat and the sun was 17 miles away.
I mean it almost is like that.
That's suppressing the growth.
The US is wacky and that we,
we have a remarkably unsophisticated scientific understanding of the way the
world works.
Yet we make all the coolest science shit.
It's really weird.
It's really weird,
you know,
as a preset for like cern,
right?
10,000 sites,
which is super cool.
Yeah.
But you know,
it,
it's a weird gig.
And you know,
I think a lot of you don't like the problematic things that pop up.
Like when you see people who were homeless,
when you see,
uh,
families with kids who don't have a job and they don't have a home,
then you want to do something to help them.
And I think having support networks and safety nets are smart,
but when you create them in such a way that you're incentivized to stay in
versus get out,
then you create an indentured class and essentially a slave class because they
can't get,
if you don't incentivize people to have self direction,
then it's easier for them to stay there.
But the easiest way to destroy a person's soul is to provide them their means in
a lottery,
cause them to suffer and to find their own way through life.
They will have no personal development character.
Right.
And the welfare state.
And I think that there's lots of good intentions that that crew,
you know,
the path to hell is paved on good intentions.
So there's a lot of desire to,
to help people.
And you know,
there's uh,
doing these more market based approaches like having,
um,
you know,
social support networks being driven more at the local level instead of the
federal level and stuff like that.
So,
you know,
there,
there's a been this thing floating around like the Cato Institute for ages where
instead of paying like 50% of my taxes to the federal government like I'm doing
now,
if I pay to a local five oh one,
three c a local nonprofit than it's dollar for dollar reduces my,
my tax burden at the federal level.
And then how,
you know,
a local nonprofit is going to be transparent,
it's going to be efficient.
If they shit the bed on something,
you can shut them down and pull your money and put it someplace else.
And you know,
there's,
there's a lot of other ways besides just expanding government it to get things
done and to take care of people.
And people look at this kind of libertarian idea as being cruel and,
and uh,
Makaveli and you know that some,
some people are going to be winners and losers losers.
That will always be the case.
But if we create a vibrant society with freedom and we respect each other's
rights and even if we don't agree,
we don't fucking each other over the differences and stuff like that,
you've got a really amazing thing that could happen from that.
And I'm,
I'm optimistic even while we've got drones flying overhead even.
Well we've got another move by our supposedly,
you know,
hope and change oriented president that wants you,
that is oriented towards more Internet suppression and more Internet monitoring.
Like it is really scary shit.
And um,
it's just wacky to me whether you're on the more liberal side or on the more
right wing conservative side,
the stuff that people will rally behind but not see the cracks and the
methodology.
It,
it's crazy to me.
I don't understand it
well.
I think people just don't look into it that deeply and they're usually really
fucking busy.
So what they do is subscribe to an ideology that makes them feel good.
Whether it's a Christian God love,
and I'm a second amendment believer and you know how many of them ever,
ever even looked into it.
They just give me my God,
that's my gun.
I mean,
are you really looking at it?
Realistically?
I support the second amendment,
but I mean,
how many people really should have guns?
How many people are fucking morons?
Right?
How many people shouldn't have cars?
I mean,
it's like we've made it so easy for someone to have the ability to use something
as crazy as a car.
And I was joking around about,
um,
I love American cars.
I love like American muscle cars.
I love that.
I mean,
it's ridiculous,
but I love that.
Like Shelby,
they're making a new Shelby gt 500 with 660 horsepower.
That's insane.
The idea that someone would need 660 fucking horsepower in a street car.
But I love the fact that you can get it right.
I love the fact that you can be a fucking idiot with 10 speeding tickets,
15 fucking crack,
as long as your insured and you have whatever it,
it costs 80 grand or where the fucking as you can go to a Ford dealership and
get by yourself a goddamn 2013 Shelby gt 500 and just drive like a maniac until
they pull you over and arrest you.
Right?
I mean it's something designed to break the law.
It's bright red and white stripes on it.
It sounds like war and it's got 660 fucking horsepower.
I love that you can just do that,
but really you shouldn't be able to,
you know really.
It is kind of fucking crazy that we allow some asshole could be texting to have
a 660 horsepower just Burt.
We trust them.
We trust them to have their shit together.
We have to figure out a way to make it so that you have to overcome something to
achieve success.
In order to feed yourself,
you've got to do some work in order to,
you know,
improve your environment and your surroundings.
You have to put forth some effort and when we make it so that people just get
checks for nothing,
that is like the complete opposite of the natural behavioral response,
Natural Award system that's set up for human means and it makes us fat cunts.
Yeah.
I mean it steals our soul.
And so you're really not helping people in that situation,
but how do you fix that though?
Once it's in place,
do you force grandma to work,
pitch,
get up,
you're going to starve to death.
You know,
like there's a lot of things like,
like instead of uh,
uh,
you know,
your going into a government pool,
maybe you manage your own health savings account and 401k and some people may
shit the bed and then you may,
you may,
you may be reliant on the,
the uh,
you know,
church is five oh one three c stuff like that.
You know,
I mean,
it,
not everybody,
it's impossible to ensure that everybody is not,
is going to be 100% taken care of it.
I think that that's a gut check for people.
They don't understand it.
You know,
like my,
my parents are unfortunately a good example.
Like my father was very smart,
but he chose not to do the things that he should have done.
And he could have had an engineering degree,
could have done drafting and stuff like that instead of just kind of fucked off.
And you really didn't have much in his later life.
And it's because,
you know,
inner child stuff,
whatever.
His father was a horrible person.
Like I get that.
Like I had a way better childhood than my dad did.
He,
he had it way more difficult than I did,
but he had choices that he could've made,
that would have provided for his family,
would have provided for himself.
And he chose not to do it.
And he had a really rough,
you know,
end of his life the last 15 years of his life sucked.
But he steered the boat that way,
you know?
And I just don't want to do that.
So it,
and I think that that's a gut check for people that
they want a safety net.
They want a safety net.
We want to be able to save everybody and they think that's what the government
is for.
The government is for a big pillow to make sure that you're going to be okay,
but when you tell people they're going to be okay,
they don't work as hard as when they don't know if they're going to be okay,
and that's what they need to do.
Yeah.
They need a little fear to motivate them.
Fuck yeah,
man.
Yeah.
I think,
I think we need that with everything.
You know?
I think everything in life is uncertain and you have to always embrace the idea
that you're a temporary being.
It's gonna sh the lights are shutting off no matter it's when fucking son
overcomes the earth is expansion.
The lights are shutting off.
You wasted in that bitch.
Right.
Get it together.
You mother fuckers,
Robb Wolf,
you're a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He dropped some serious knowledge on his podcast.
I really,
really appreciate it,
man.
Thank you man.
So informative and interesting and I bet we could probably do 10 of these,
right?
Tell me when you want me back and I'll do it again.
I'll bring the mixed drinks next time I'm bringing,
I'm,
I'm reading your book as of today and I'm going to get that shit.
I can't get it from audible.com you son of a bitch.
I'll get right on it.
So I'll send it to you before I send it to them.
I promise.
Get it from Amazon.
I'll get it from him.
I know.
I'll get it from Doug.
That's right,
right.
Get it from Doug G,
g e d but we want to thank audible.com for being our sponsor today.
We also want to thank Alienware supplying us with these dope ass laptops and if
you're really,
that would be the only,
only our sponsor,
but they hooked us up and if you are interested in gaming laptops,
you can't do any better than these Alienware things.
They're fucking giant bricks.
But the graphics power is fucking staggering already game.
The three d gaming is really cool.
I've been doing a lot of other shit and they support fighters and that's why we
support them.
Alien ware,
MMA on Twitter.
Go follow them.
Follow Robb Wolf on Twitter with two B's.
That's Robb Wolf on Twitter and thank you to audible.com and a,
if you go to audible podcast dot forward slash Joe Rogan,
you can,
uh,
I don't know.
I fucking,
something happens like,
guess shit happens.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I think they get a free trial.
Something happens.
They give you something,
they'll give you some cool shit,
but it's a great service and I'm a huge fan of audible books,
audio books.
They're great to listen to in the car.
They literally make traffic dissolve.
All you think about is what you're hearing and the story.
It's,
it's a chance for you to instead listen some stupid gossip news or some
depressing shit about the world.
You can get lost in some cool fiction or some informative stuff.
Or you know,
you could,
uh,
listen to our friend Bobcat Goldthwait in his book.
I don't mean to insult you,
but you look like bobcat.
Both.
Wait,
that's my recommendation and one that has helped me tremendously,
the war of art by Steven Pressfield winning the inner creative battle.
It's a really amazing and inspirational book that I really enjoy and you can get
that from audible.com.
Thank you.
Also to [inaudible] dot com go to o n and it and use the code named rogue and
you will save 10% of all your supplements like Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom tech sport with the quadriceps mushroom that we discussed earlier and a
shroom tech,
immune shroom tech,
whatever.
We need shrimp deck Dick hard.
And that's um,
that's the Combo.
You should do that,
man.
They're,
they're working on some shit from that spider.
That wandering spider that makes your Dick hard kills you.
They're working on some of that.
You know about that Chilean wandering spider.
The Brazilian wondering spider gives you,
uh,
when it stings you,
it kills more people than any spider in the world.
But it kills you by making your Dick hard.
It makes you,
it makes your whole body like stiff and rigid.
It says something to your nitric oxide and it gives you a hard on that if you
survive the bite,
which most people don't,
your Dick is broken forever.
It really blows up like a sausage on a grill.
It pops the casing.
This just sounds like all upside,
but they've got some pharmaceutical dude's trying to figure out how to use this.
Spiders properties.
It's probably be the next Spiderman movie in the Spiderman movie.
Everybody has a hundred on directions running,
screaming hard ons that explode a on at.com.
Oh and and it get yourself some kettle bells son.
Get all fucking manly like Robb wolf and get some battle ropes and all that good
shit.
Um,
uh,
but with the supplements,
you use the code name rogue and save yourself 10% off the kettle bells.
We are selling them as cheap as we humanly possibly can.
It is a crazy business.
I'm so sorry for all those ups drivers out there.
We're sending fucking cannon balls with handles through the mail.
Uh,
the battle ropes are the cheapest you can get on the Internet and that is a
fact.
They are the cheapest and the best at [inaudible] dot com go get some you dirty
bitches.
We'll see you tomorrow with Maynard from tool.
We have a huge show tomorrow night in sale,
and here's the lineup.
We have a Joe Rogan,
Joey Diaz is Josh McDermitt,
Billy Bucknell and Randy leaky from the bone zone.
And you,
Tony Hinchcliffe and me and Brian Red band.
So fucking powerful show.
Ladies and gentlemen,
he can't get any better than that.
10 30 Friday at the Ice House.
One of the oldest comedy clubs in North Shit's
been here in the 60 [inaudible] son.
All right.
Show's over.
See you guys tomorrow.
We love you all.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Okay.